e
good morning everybody Welcome to
uh criminal justice and Public
Safety uh before we open our first
hearing if you would all please join me
Allegiance right
so I am opening the public hearing for
House Bill 194 relative to the crime of
interference with custody and I
recognize the prime sponsor
representative love um to present his
Bill thank you madam chair and and
members of the criminal justice
committee I'm not the prime I'm uh
co-sponsor on this but uh the prime
prime sponsor wasn't available today uh
my name is uh representative David love
I represent the town of bar Rockingham
13 and uh I come come before you today
to introduce House Bill 194 an act
relative to interference with child
custody the intent of House Bill 194 is
to amend New Hampshire RSA 633 colon 4
to strengthen the current statute which
already recognizes the withholding minor
children under age 18 from a parent
guardian or other person having lawful
rights and responsibilities as described
in RSA
461a is either a class me felony If the
child is removed from the state or MISD
demean a crime from within the
state unfortunately current law
enforcement often incorrectly tells
tells an aggrieved par parent that it's
a civil matter for the family courts to
adjudicate and they should file for
Relief through the family court it's not
unusual for a hearing to request a
hearing request to take six to eight
weeks amending our current law with
House Bill 194 will strengthen the law
by emphasizing penalties for the first
and second offense making both first and
second offense of misdemeanor and a
class B felony penalties for third and
subsequent offenses by specifying
specifying these penalties House Bill
194 will Al also hopefully ensure that
the Court's order is enforced by any no
Hampshire law enforcement
agency we all know that any law without
penalties is a worthless piece of paper
it's imperative to recognize the
fundamental rights of parents in raising
and having access to their children
parental rights not just legal
formalities they're an essential an
essential and emotional and
psychological well-being of both the
child and parent every parent has the
right to be involved in their child's
life to nurture them guide them and
provide them with the stability and love
they need to thrive unfortun
unfortunately many divorcing couples are
so enraged that they can't see the
emotional damage they're inflicting on
their beloved children much less
understand the long-term damage that
often caused by their own selfish
behavior a broken home is devastating
for children children and being forcibly
kept from either loving parent is
something we have a chance to prevent
kids need both parents this fundamental
right ensures that children receive
balanced upbringing emotional support
and the diverse perspectives that only
both parents can
provide I urge you my colleagues to
support HBO 194 and join me in taking a
stand against C custody interference by
doing so we're not only upholding the
law but also protecting the sacred bond
between parents and their children
together we can make a difference in the
lives of countless families and children
who deserve to live a safe and in a St
safe and stable
environment thank you for your attention
I hopefully for your commitment to this
important issue and I ask you to vote
out to pass on House Bill
share uh my concern uh with this is is
um uh paragraph the new paragraph five
making it a a a felony to knowingly or
purposely interfere with a lawful court
order um it's already uh uh if you f
fair to say that it's it's a misdemeanor
to uh violate a court order it's
contempt of court you agree with
that to violate a a court order should
be contempt of court really it is
contempt of court so my question is
why why why do we why does why do you
and the co Prime sponsor want
to enter a felony into the mix of the
difficult process of people divorcing
and and dealing with child custody why a
felony rather than a misdemeanor I
felony excuse you're correct it's a
felony if you take it out take the child
out of the state why do we want that um
well if you don't be if you don't want
to be arrested for selling drugs don't
sell drugs if you don't want to be
arrested for
for child um you know keeping children
away from a parent that has legal right
to them don't do it don't do it a third
time all right I don't have anything
forther any further questions seeing
Albert good morning Mr chair and members
of the committee uh my name is Dana alre
nashille New Hampshire uh father of four
children and I have certainly been a
victim of this sort of thing while my
oldest child lives with me and the
younger three have since aged out uh my
family uh situation involved a
seven-year Odyssey of the younger three
kids being taken through multiple
States uh California Michigan
Massachusetts kind of all One Step of
ahead of the courts and nobody knew
where they
were so interference with custody is
definitely a problem and I am 100% on
board and
cheering uh sort of the speech I just
heard on what we're trying to accomplish
with this I think that's laudable and I
think we need to do something because we
have a statute that's not being enforced
that being said there's some language in
the bill is written that I find
extremely problematic and I think the
bill as written would actually weaken
the statute so it's my hope we can kind
of just tease that all apart and pass
something to strengthen this that's a
good
bill
uh very
specifically
uh excuse
me
uh uh line
24 uh where it discusses fleeing the
commission of attempted Commission of
domestic or violence as those terms are
used in RSA
173b uh I think that's extremely
problematic
because uh RSA 173b is a civil
statute uh it's
being uh used to weaponize the family
courts uh if you are now inserting that
as affirmative defense all any
unscrupulous person needs to do is uh
run down and get an automatic civil
order and now they've got a an out to go
commit a serious
crime uh so you know as a matter of
first principles I think anytime you put
civil and criminal law together and try
and mix them up and it's unclear which
is which you need to be really careful
about what you're doing and unintended
consequences
there uh I do have a handout here I
apologize there's only a couple copies
uh printer Jam this morning uh that
describes the systematic abuse of uh
civil demestic statutes under
173b so uh and how that's actually a
serious problem in New Hampshire right
now where you have criminals who go get
an order against their
victims and now you've got the the
criminals gold and he get he or she gets
out of everything and that's just not
okay um that being said again forgive me
there's only a couple copies of this
then I'll take questions if you just
give them to the representative on the
end we'll have our committee assistant
you with that being
said with regard to the rest of the bill
did you say that you were in favor of it
section so uh specifically not because
of this one section but let me add to
accomplish what I think the sponsors
want to
accomplish I would just add something
very simple to the statute along the
lines that if a peace officer has
probable cause to believe that someone
has violated the statute the peace offic
or shall keyword being shall investigate
write a report something to that effect
because the real problem right now is we
have a statute that's good enough it's
not perfect but it's good enough and
it's just simply going completely
unforced and you know as representative
of Love said uh when people call the
cops they're incorrectly told it's a
civil matter that's the problem right
there just kind of if it were me kind of
scrap all of this in in terms of
language and just put in something
simple that if people call the cops and
the cops are probable cause they shall
investigate thank you any questions for
the
m i noticed that the bill uh doesn't
actually change the first four parts of
the current statute the bill is actually
an addition to to the current statute
what I'm curious about is what the
problem is that you're really trying to
solve with the bill um
so I I don't believe he testified he was
in favor of this bill so I'm sorry I I
don't believe he testified he was in
favor of this
bill I think the problems have been
clearly articulated by rep love and I
think just tacking this language onto
that doesn't solve those problems but I
think we really need to solve those
problems and he articulated those
problems that we really need to solve
extremely well thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
Dart I apologize if I didn't get the
good morning Mr chair members of the K
committee for the record my name is Gail
drat Amhurst New
Hampshire
um as our elected policymakers you have
the greatest stability reform outdated
laws to better protect Children and
Families interference with custody has
been a crime in all 50
states in 1983 New Hampshire enacted
this law recognizing when a child is
withheld from a parent guardian or other
person having lawful physical custody it
is a crime in 2005 HB 640 amended
6334 to add the language of with lawful
parental rights and responsibilities as
responsibilities as outlined in current
law when a parent with lawful parental
rights and responsibilities as described
in 461a engages with the law enfor
forcement to report the crime of
interference with custody they are
instructed to go back to court it's a
civil
matter when an officer makes that
statement it is contrary to the crime of
interference with custody and fails to
equally protect the child and both
parents if a parent is withholding a
minor child for safety concerns they
have an obligation to report child abuse
or neglect or file an expar relief with
family court more often not than not
they are withholding the minor child
never reporting the child abuse and
never filing with the
court this causes harm to children
creating attachment bonds with the minor
child and one parent when this happens
the agreed parent targeted parent has to
petition the court pay an additional fee
to reopen a case that has been
adjudicated the parent has been deemed
fit and has lawful parental rights and
responsibilities under 461 as outlined
in current
law it could be several months before
the aggrieved parent can get a hearing
in the Circuit Court and rarely does the
judge hold the obstructing parent in
contempt of the already adjudicated
court order there is no relief for the
innocent parent or more importantly the
innocent children when law enforcement
refuses to enforce the law this
amendment to current law is not intended
to have parents arrested that should be
a last resort the intent of this
legislation is to ensure the god-given
rights of children and their fundamental
right to maintain a loving meaningful
relationship with both parents after
separation or divorce is upheld this can
only happen when law enforcement informs
the instructing obstructing parent of
the consequences for interfering with
custody or enforce the law of
interference with custody when New
Hampshire law enforcement and the courts
fail to enforce the laws they have been
leg that you have legislated they are
breaching their contract and oath they
have taken to secure their position as a
public
servant when the oath is breached and
the laws are breached deprivation of
rights under color of law are being
committed harming New Hampshire Children
and Families federal constitutional
rights are being deprived under inferior
State statutes for these reasons I
respectfully ask each of you to support
the passage of this
Bill thank you any questions for the
witness
yes thank you for for being here the
previous speaker said that he thinks the
current law would be helped
if we just had language that said that
peace officers need to understand it's
not a civil matter it's a criminal
matter would you agree with that I 100%
agree with that
and you could forgo this whole bill and
simply add a line in there that they
need to enforce court orders that have
been adjudicated the parent has been
deemed fit and in current law if you
look I think I added that to my
testimony up there they have 72 hours to
file a report if there is legitimate and
it's not happening they're withholding
the child and these children are not
seeing their other parents for months
months years and you'll hear testimony
to that today so it needs to be enforced
they have a draw law enforcement I
mean thank you our justice system is
failing epically and I don't know where
we lost that um we need to get it
back thank you you're welcome any
further
questions seeing none thank you for your
Tes thank you very
much the chair calls uh The Honorable
Betty
gay
and Mr
chairman honorable well repr
Representatives I'm happy to be here um
as you know as you may know I've been
trying for several years to chip away at
injustices that are going on in Family
Court not because somebody wants them to
be unfair it's just the laws haven't
been written
adequately so this is to correct a real
serious issue that probably stems back
from the historic attitude of law
enforcement to domes stics do you
remember years ago they would say it's
just a
domestic that finally ended in
Connecticut about 40 years ago when a
woman knew that her estranged husband
who had a court order a restraining
order was coming to her house so she
called the police and said the guy's
coming to the house they said it's just
a domestic we'll show up later well by
the time they got back she was in
terrible shape he had he had assaulted
her so badly she spent time in the
hospital then she sued them in those
days a million dollars was a lot of
money the town had to pay and everybody
said oh it's a demestic I guess we have
to show up so I think it's historic that
that's attitude is that uh any kind of
domestic dispute is civil not criminal
but this law has been on the book
now the one I gave a packet that has
colored paper so this colored paper this
color is the original law that this uh
Amendment will just add to it doesn't
change
anything um on N Roman numeral two a
person's guilty of a misdemeanor if such
person knowingly takes entices detains
conceals a child under the age of 18 or
CA causes any such child to be taken
enticed detained or concealed with
intent to detain or conceal such child
from either a person or an agency that
has the right to guard that child so
this is not a New Concept the trouble is
it's new to our police force and when I
asked I called the AG's office first to
find out who does have authority this is
really either a misdemeanor
or a
felony that's not civil and I even had
that discussion with I have in my town
we have very respectable people I trust
as Chief and a deputy chief and they
still think this is civil so we need the
top law enforcement of the state to
confirm that it is their responsibility
and one of the qu to enforce it and one
of the questions was well have do they
know what to enforce well after spending
thousands to go to court and get your
court order you've got something in
writing with a date on it that says what
you're entitled to so you could show
that to whatever police our uh law
enforcement officer comes to the
house um and it's got a date because the
two parents you know here's one parent
coming to pick the child up the other
parent has a child so they should both
be there um so you do have some written
proof right there what I was told by the
AG's office is we don't do that the
sheriff does that well I don't know
about most of you but I can't just pick
up the phone and call the sheriff I
really think this ought to be just a
simple matter I don't think it'll take
too many uh charges of
misdemeanor and it is a misdemeanor not
a felony for the first two times I think
after twice you should get the message
um because we've had people sitting at
these tables just last year two women
from conquer both of them have the
documents from the court giving them
50%
custody they haven't seen their children
in over a year because the police won't
do it and School departments are really
scared to do anything that's the least
bit questionable that's my personal
experience I can't show you that in
engraved in Granite anywhere but this is
a serious problem and it to me is just
ludicrous to be told well that's a civil
matter so go back to court okay if I'm
holding a court order what good is it to
going to go get another
one so this simply says that this I
thought it was pretty neat that the
wording changed now this you all do you
version they did go print them but the
first the first things they printed were
the original without the corrections the
only difference between the original um
194 and this amended version is uh under
line five underline line five now has
now includes one
two b and a b and c and before that was
broken into two different paragraphs
instead of one that's the only change
there and then the real important change
was to say what the penal the penalty is
because the first version actually had
fines well money changes every year
value of it that's silly to tie to a a
fine so this one simply
says with real
teeth you're guilty of a misdemeanor the
first or second event so you get a if
you slip up once and find out you were
wrong you do have a chance to set that
right but according to uh some parents
who refuse to part with a child and I'm
sure it's because they think nothing's
going to happen to them now they're
guilty of a clasby felony that's really
serious ious I think that is a
deterrent and I just hope that we can
get law
enforcement
aware and accepting of a sticky
situation it's not fun to go to a house
and tell a parent you have to give your
child up to this other
parent um I realize I
realize that anybody who's I I let's put
it like this I have no attorneys who
wouldn't be caught dead doing family law
there's just so much emotional baggage
and risk that it's not a fun situation
so I understand why police would be just
really happy if we keep this civil so
they don't have to but parents who've
gone through hell sometimes to get the
right to see their
children my husband being one out of
state um they need they they deserve to
enforced thank you representative could
you tell
me how the changes that are being
proposed will make it any more likely
that the police will enforce the law
stands well we're just hoping that
bringing the subject up and making it
heard publicly that this is a crime to
withhold um
maybe yeah the more people who are aware
of this I think we have a better chance
of reaching the top LW enforcement in
the state I'd certainly be happy to go
knock on his door again I was well
received for another subject
before it would would it not be possible
for us to Simply write a bill that says
the attorney General will um put out uh
an
opinion letting the police departments
know that this is indeed a criminal
statute and they should be enforcing it
I would love that amend away
representative
Sher thank you for your
testimony uh following up on on the
chair's question um
my experience is uh on a daily
basis uh the
people the law enforcement entities who
need to know that uh these are crimes
and not civil matters are the city or
Municipal prosecutors or the county
attorney's offices uh I would you know
in in line with what the chair was
suggesting I would suggest reaching out
to the uh County attorneys Association
and and I can after this is over tell
you who to talk to and and and they need
to educate police departments they're
the ones in the first instance who are
educating police departments and and
that might accomplish what uh What uh I
think is a laudable goal to get get the
statute even as it exists now uh
enforced any further
questions seeing none thank you
thank you much every idea you have is
Representatives not really sure if I'm
for this bill or against this bill I'm
not really sure if I'm confused or all
of you are
confused um 1911 the 61st Congress
abolished all circuit courts we were in
this building last year and testified
that rep Smith asked uh cab that if
Circuit Court was a leg a constitutional
court and she said
no there's one problem you guys need to
investigate number two a duty to give
decision which are advisory only and so
without Force as judicial judgments may
be laid upon the legislative court but
not a constitutional court on
established under article 3 Williams
1933 um probable CS can't come from
civil court uh that's part of the
Constitution that's what it
says um I've gotten 6 hours and 12 years
with my son in New Hampshire family
court because 16 Jud judges got
immunity when I have five pages of case
law from the Supreme Court that says
Bond the United States people are
sovereign and not the state of the
government so why are these judges
giving
immunity the
negligence from Family
Court sorry hold on give me one second
it so getting back to the
173b uh obviously if it's a statute it
has to match the Constitution if it's
not it's unconstitutional and the only
way to be charged with a statute is if
you give consent it's also in the
Constitution so the negligence from
Family
Court by using criminal statutes such as
633 uh against litigant and civil court
without evidence because Rules of
Evidence don't apply if there was
actually probable evidence of an actual
crime the family courts are liable for
not reporting to an actual Criminal
Court only criminal courts are supposed
to be Pro Prosecuting criminal codes not
these family
courts uh Family Court likes to say that
they give civil sanctions but it's
actually the criminal code so why is
Family Court offering criminal code in
Family Court without evidence title 62
section 625 through6 651 only and not
173 and in US code's only Title
so these Family Court judges for 12
years have been fighting to see my
son
um and obviously they don't care about
evidence so judge Gardner which I guess
recently retired he wrote in an order on
4324 that it's the preponderance of the
evidence and Rules of Evidence don't
apply so obviously he intentionally
misled every
here or some of you that was here and
other people that were not um so
preponderance of the evidence is greater
than 50% true but if Rules of Evidence
don't apply that means the evidence is
inadmissible it's unreliable it's
incomplete and it's not it's not
believable so you guys have a lot of
work to do because you can't have propon
of the evidence and you can't have Rules
of Evidence don't apply that's what
judge Gardner wrote and then he said
Rules of Evidence don't apply to the mo
to the motion that I seek to
vacate so why would a family court
judge deny the motion to vacate a
protective order a criminal protective
order in Family Court when evidence
didn't
apply he wrote it I have
it um New Hampshire Supreme Court denied
a rident Tory two district courts denied
my case US court of appeals denied my
case um and they all cited Rooker Felman
which is weird because the bear case
um you guys have a lot of work to do
should probably read the Constitution
before you start drafting these bills so
you you stay in line with the
law
um I'd love to take questions I have a
and furthermore the state cab was in
here
before and she's like well you know the
people go to the judicial conduct
committee because that's the committee
that people are that for law
complaints well that's weird cuz I have
a letter from the judicial conduct
committee that says they can't hear
administrative law complaints so again
rep cutab was in here misleading
everybody intentionally because I have
the letters to prove
it so if you really want to stop this
child abuse and neglect and Mis prison
and page and slavery and kidnapping
against our
kids let's get back to the Constitution
I don't understand 12 years protective
order no evidence evidence didn't
apply
so I have all the paperwork I just filed
a motion for habius Corpus on Friday in
District Court for the Attorney General
to actually answer a question under oath
because he's he's failed four years in a
row um I wonder why they get immunity
for
that I'll take any questions but I'm not
how do criminal statutes in Family Court
without evidence anybody have a question
anybody have an answer to that I would
love to hear
it see no questions thank you for your
testimony who's next anyone else wishing
to testify who hasn't turned into pink
card seeing none I hear by close the
e
here I open the public hearing on House
Bill 257 and I'd ask the prime sponsor
come thank you Mr chair um for the
record I'm representative skip Rollins
representing newa Unity Chown Sullivan
District 3 has brought to my attention
earlier this year uh or last year um for
a bill for child neglect of a case we
had in Newport and by uh detective Alex
Marvin um I am going to just speak to
this open this up I'm going to leave the
testimony to a number of experts I
brought down we've got the police
department the uh County attorneys and
the grandmother that like to speak today
I don't want to be redundant so I will
turn it over to the first person on the
list or who we have next thank you thank
you
representative Emily gared and Christine
Sullivan
uh good morning chairman Roy uh and
members of the committee our names are
Emily Gad and Christine Sullivan I am
the
straford Christine hilard of the
Sullivan County Attorney's Office she's
the Sullivan County attorney my name is
Emily grod I am the straford county
attorney and we are here to testify in
favor of hb27 FN establishing the crime
of criminal neglect of a child also
known as Charlotte's law I have been a
criminal prosecutor for almost 10 years
and have been involved in hundreds of
criminal investigations pertaining to
child abuse I am also a member of the
Children's Justice act task force of the
Granite State Children's Alliance and
the Attorney General's task force on
child abuse neglect I believe it is time
that New Hampshire join the majority of
other states in criminalized child
neglect presently law enforcement is
limited with the charges it can bring
against those who injure children
through neglect while we are sometimes
able to bring assault charges jurors
have difficulty labeling injuries caused
by neglect as assault the endangering
the welfare of a child statute is very
specific and only encompasses a very n
narrow set of circumstances additionally
there is no statute which addresses
instances where caregivers fail to
protect a child from sexual
assault I prosecuted a 16-year-old
juvenile a couple years back who was
sexually assaulting his younger brother
when that victim came forward at age 11
he disclosed not only the sexual abuse
at the hands of his brother but also
that he had told their father about the
sexual abuse and that their father did
nothing to address or prevent it his
father's inaction caused him to continue
to be sexually abused and he until he
disclosed to a third party this inaction
also delayed his abuser's ability to get
the help that he needed to address his
sexualized
behaviors while the juvenile was
adjudicated through the juvenile system
no charges could be brought against the
father I believe this statute will be a
valuable tool and more importantly a
meaningful deterrent to child neglect in
cases of dcyf involvement it can
motivate a caregiver to comply with a
safety plan I believe this bill is
necessary to address the gaps in how New
Hampshire prevents and addresses child
abuse and neglect and I ask that you
find hb27 FN ought to pass happy to take
has um did you plan on testifying
councelor too so I would Echo attorney
garage statement and I'd also say I
think this bill fills a hole that exists
in our current stat ratory
scheme another example of conduct that
sort of gets put into another place but
should be really child neglect is
there's often instances where a child
gets into some sort of controlled
substance and does not die uh there is
sometimes serious harm but since there
is no death it does not fit into the
negligent homicide statute this would
allow us to prosecute that currently
other counties are putting that into a
statute called Reckless conduct with a
deadly weapon I think this much better
fits what is happening there uh so I do
think that this addresses a hole in our
criminal statutes I do think that the
bill put forth is narrowly tailored uh I
have spoken with representative Sher to
address a language comment uh so we're
happy to include changing the language
of who is responsible for the child
neglect uh to sort of mirror what's
already done and the endangering the
welfare of child or incompetent in 639
colon 3 but I do think this fills a gap
and we're happy to take any questions I
have a a quick question I notice you
have um necessary Medical Care um does
this bill leave any type of exemption
for um some people for religious reasons
who decide that they don't want to do
certain things what what's the
definition of necessary medical care so
I do think when looking at necessary
medical care I think we're looking at
truly necessary medical care I think
what was going to happen in in
situations like that is the state's
going to have to procure an expert to
say that this is necessary medical care
when you're talking about some topics
where there are disagreements for
example vaccines uh you're going to be
in a situation where there's going to be
a medical professional who is going to
be able to take the stand and say for
the defense Council that this is not
medically necessary and so as a
prosecutor it is our duty to make sure
that we bring a charge that we have a
good faith basis to believe we can prove
Beyond a reasonable doubt if there's not
then we won't be able to bring that
charge so I do think that a lot of that
is sort of subsumed by that exception
just as a prosecutor we have to believe
we can bring it and actually prove it
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and on
something like vaccines where there are
medical experts who will testify both
ways I don't think we could ask a jury
to find Beyond a reasonable doubt that a
vaccine was medically
necessary no I'm assuming perhaps
something that is obviously medically
necessary but for some people um I
understand there are certain religions
where they say you know we're just going
to leave it up to God and not I think
I'm trying to think um which one it is
but I I remember a case in Pennsylvania
I think um where parents um weren't
treating a bacterial infection or
something like that and the child was
getting sicker and it ended up in do we
have any type of a um in this law is it
compliment contemplate it or have you
thought about a defense where someone
could say it's our religious right not
to treat this but I'm trying to do is
make sure that we don't go down
somewhere where we end up wrecking that
something that's really good in this law
so that is not contemplated in the
statute as it currently is that's
certainly something that that could be
addressed in an addition um I don't know
if attorney Gro has any further comments
on that so in the statute that I re
statutes that I researched across the
country there were some that included a
provision uh for those who for religious
reasons didn't seek their child to have
medical care however if you got into a
situation where a child was um dying or
passed away because their parents had a
religious belief that they shouldn't be
obtaining medical care that person would
still have been found um neglectful um
through the division of child of
children youth and families um whether
or not that we want to prosecute that
person I think
um I think that we would and I think
that that would fit under a negligent
homicide statute for instance and
there's no religious exemption for that
um the reason we sought to include this
law is because we find ourselves
twisting to fit certain circumstances in
the assault Statute in the ENT homicide
statute and his County attorney um
hilard said um in unless a child dies
there's really no remedy for it so I
would uh urge the committee um to pass
this bill because I do believe that um
that it is worth Prosecuting those cases
even where there might be a religious
belief um if there if there happens to
be serious bodily injury but again it's
something that could be done with an
amendment if you found that religious um
for religious reasons somebody wasn't
obtaining medical Medical Care
and if that instance didn't result in
serious bodily injury or death maybe
that's where you make the amendment but
I do think that children are who are um
have injuries that are resulting in
serious bodily injury or death uh that
that shouldn't be
covering basically I just I think that
this has probably been already um um
litigated somewhere um perhaps even up
to the Supreme Court so I what I'd like
to do is be sure that there's not
already some case law out there that we
could tailor this language to that so if
you could maybe take a look and see you
said you'd found some cases I I I was
looking at uh statutes that other states
have passed for child neglect or their
versions of endangering the welfare of a
okay of a child
um I have not done outside Research into
whether those statutes were upheld by
their Supreme Courts but I would assume
that if they have that provision in
there they're still on the books they
probably are good all right thank you
any further questions representative m
um along the lines of what uh
representative Roy was asking I noticed
that um in the definitions we have a
definition for necessary care but we
don't have definitions for necessary
food necessary clothing necessary
medical care or necessary shelter do you
feel um that without definitions those
that language is
ambiguous I do not I think that would
ultimately come down to the question of
the decider of fact and in the criminal
world that is the jury so I think the
jury would be left to determine was that
necessary food was that necessary
clothing or was that necessary shelter
and I think that's the appropriate
instance any further questions
representative um
Ro thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I I would just like
to to clarify so I know there's times
when a school district would call say
DCF
and many many examples I'm sure that
that you can think of quickly as well
and the response that is often told
is they're doing the best they can right
and when a reasonable person will look
at it and say that it it is clearly
neglect I mean it's you know continuous
and continuous and continuous so I'm
looking at the examples that you that
are here like under one and then it says
you know a through F would that be
basically that exception as well they're
doing the best that they can would that
fall under
these are are you talking about I'm
sorry I don't think I understand yeah so
so there's been examples where the
school will call DCF right and the and
and the complaint might be um the person
where it's it's it's
physically obvious that there is neglect
happening whether it be they're not
eating at home or the child is telling
us that right and again these are
sometimes their worst case scenarios but
they do exist
or
unimaginable filth that the child is is
coming to school repeatedly right so
when we would call
DCF then what we what we hear on the
other line is oh well we know we know
that family and well she's doing the
best that she can or he's doing the best
that they can so would that they're
doing the best that they can kind of
fall under where it says
here basically you know for reasons
other than like poverty is that is this
would would that still be the exception
here
so when you have DCF involved DCF gets a
report of abuse and neglect they are
doing what they can to provide the
family with the services they need to
help that person be a better parent and
take care of their child whether that's
assistance through Wick or um support
with finding food or shelter necessary
care this is meant to address the people
that are ignoring that help and um a
child being harmed because their parent
is being neglectful in spite of the
resources that dcyf is providing them
for example I find experience in cases
quite frequently where you have DCF and
that's why I put this in here an active
safety plan to say um in order to be
provide for this child dcyf is
instructing you that you need to comply
with a safety plan that says you need to
do X Y and Z to make sure that your
child is safe this is to address the
parents that are saying no and putting
their child at risk anyway I think it
gives DCF some teeth um you know I think
these crimes on the books are meant
mostly to be deterrence to people to
commit for committing crimes and if dcyf
can say you know there will be
ramifications if you do not comply with
this safety plan and you never know the
police department could also bring
charges of criminal neglect against you
maybe that parent uh will then change
their mind and provide for that child
when there's an actual real threat there
to them I would Echo that and I think
one of the things that we see often
ignored in safety plans are
investigations of child sexual abuse and
in that instance usually the child is
safety planned out of the home home or
out of the care of the suspect uh often
times the parent the child is left with
continues to bring that child to the
suspect or let that person live with
them and that child sometimes not always
but sometimes under goes further abuse
and this law would allow us to do
something about that rather than simply
say there's not really a good way to
charge that uh the only other place that
could be charged is a class A
misdemeanor for a failure to report the
thank you if if I could just clarify so
what you're saying is this this
legislation will actually make it easier
if indeed the person does have a plan
because I think you would agree a lot of
them do and it's blatantly obvious that
it is being ignored this will actually
make it easier for the state to be able
representative
Sher uh any interest of full disclosure
uh Sullivan County attorney Miss hilard
has The Misfortune of having been a
student of mine
um we spoke
um yesterday I believe and I expressed a
concern with the word responsible in
line five uh and we agreed that uh a
better language would be the language
from the endangering the welfare statute
which we you would replace responsible
with um a duty of care protection or
support the person owes to such child
that is correct and I would also I
wouldn't know if I would say Misfortune
but I I did see you a lot over my three
years uh thank you well probably not as
much as we have yeah follow-up question
follow up it it remains to be seen to
the outcome of a a child abuse or
neglect proceeding in the D DC might be
the termination of parental rights so
that's an alternative to if the the
family the parents don't comply with the
uh plan of
DCF uh that's an alternative uh to a
criminal charge um is that fair to say
uh it is I don't know if I agree with
the term alternative it's a possible
outcome and it's a very lengthy process
uh I believe you cannot terminate a
parent rights until a year you've given
them a year to comply with a safety plan
so I guess I'm sorry followup
um what I'm struggling with is
um that's one
outcome um the other outcome is a
criminal charge which might result in
incarceration uh I'm struggling
with that being a better potential
outcome than the uh the termination of
parental rights that's that's my concern
with the statute as a whole I understand
the concern of while that might be a
better outcome for the parent um I think
the outcome for the child is what I'm um
I guess more more focused on I think
incarceration for some of the more minor
um fact patterns that you can imagine
that would fit under this statute uh is
a stretch I think most people that have
no criminal history or no um background
of being neglectful uh would have a an
outcome that reflected the behavior in
itself we also have a multitude of
resources in the criminal justice system
other than incarceration that I think
could help get a parent back on track
such as probation or deferred sentences
something that would give them a real
incentive to comply with um with the
safety plan with dcyf with being a
better less neglectful caregiver um so I
think that
incarceration while it could be a risk
to the more egregious offenders um
there's also a lot more that we can do
uh again to motivate people to help be a
better parent and ultimately we want
what we want to do is deter this conduct
uh and keep it from continuing this
statute would also fall under the um I
think it's 650 won uh an nment standard
so if you had a misdemeanor um criminal
neglect of a child you did what you were
supposed to do you went on to have no
criminal history you could get this ma
uh matter uned in a matter of years for
class I misdemeanor the annulment window
is three years from completion of the
sentence so I do agree there is the
option DCF certainly has the option of
going down a path of terminating
parental rights but I would agree with
attorney Gad I think uh the county
attorney's office spends a lot of time
looking at not just the charged crime
but who is the alleged person committing
it and how do we best find a measure of
punishment deterrence and Rehabilitation
which is what the Supreme Court says are
the factors that make up a good sentence
and how do we ultimately prevent what is
happening from occurring again and you
see that two people are often not
treated the exact same they're treated
based off who they are uh and you see
that in you know drug cases uh simple
possession cases someone's not going to
the House of Corrections for having a
couple of bags of heroin or fentol if
they have absolutely nothing else on
their criminal history even if they do
have things on their criminal history
it's very rare at least I would say in
my office that they're going to the
House of Corrections for that uh and I
think the same would happen here it
would also allow us to make complying
with dcyf a term of their sentence which
again provides more teeth to trying to
get them on the right path and to get
those children out of Harm's way sooner
than that year rather than putting them
through a whole year and having their
rights
terminated thank you a representative
n thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um what I'm trying to
um gauge uh in in terms of the outcome
for the child right um what I'm trying
to gauge is kind of I guess what is the
uh what is the standard for you know uh
it's easy to understand when we're
talking about uh matters of sexual abuse
um or you know something that is
straightforward like that when we're
talking about um food clothing uh
medical care I think a lot of these
things what I'm what I'm wondering is
what would uh what would the uh standard
have to be for someone to be charged
under this so it's a a negligent mental
standard which uh I would stress to the
committee is higher than a civil
negligence standard and that um standard
comes directly from uh the New Hampshire
Supreme Court so in order to be
negligent you have to have um the
carelessness required for criminal
negligence is appreciably more serious
than that for ordinary civil negligence
and its seriousness must be apparent to
anyone who shares the community's
general sense of right and wrong it
requires not only the failure to
perceive a more than ordinary risk but
also some serious blameworthy conduct so
we would be talking about only conduct
that falls under that um Supreme Court
definition of criminal negligence thank
you
no thank you for taking my question
whenever a penalty is not a maximum
minimum how much discretion does a judge
have in
discretion as long as it's not a
mandatory sentence the judge and the
prosecution has complete discretion we
have complete discretion what we offer
and the judge has complete discuss to
don't thank you for taking my question
uh many years ago I was on the school
board and we had a child who was
constantly in trouble at the bus stop in
the classroom on the playground
constantly in
trouble always coming up before the
school board his child was in the second
grade he lived with his
father come to find out the child was
being exposed to pornography on a daily
basis would that fit within this
proposed
law sorry in court you have to hold it
to be muted I didn't realize I had to
turn it back on uh under the catchall
for necessary care I believe you could
um make an argument for that that it's
uh necessary care to provide that it
puts them at risk for a serious harm um
but I do think you'd need to as a
prosecutor get an expert to say exposure
to pornography put this kid at risk for
uh X Y and Z so um I do think that there
is an Avenue to do
that don't don't we already have a
statute um with regard to giving
pornography to
minors there's the obscene matter
statute which I've rarely ever seen
charged um and I'm not I think I've
looked at it before and showing it to a
child is not necessarily encompassed in
that but I'd have to check that to to be
honest with you there are statutes that
prohibit uh if you were to expose
yourself to a child that is covered but
I'm I in that statute I know it doesn't
thank you some somebody ought to make a
law
um thank you no further questions thank
you um I a subcommittee on this bill if
you um are willing to help with that um
good morning chairman Roy and members of
the committee my name is Alex Marvin
I've been a police officer for nearly 10
years and I currently serve as the
commander of the criminal investigations
division at the Newport Police
Department I oversee all cases of child
uh abuse in our community uh hundred
handling hundreds of cases over my
career I'm here to testify in support of
H b257 establishing the crime of
criminal neglect of a child children are
the most vulnerable victims in our
society they often lack the ability to
speak for themselves and when they do
they may not have a safe or supportive
adult to advocate for them becomes our
responsibility as Law Enforcement
Officers to be their voice and protect
them when they cannot protect themselves
the stakes are incredibly high in these
investigations if handled improperly the
consequences are not just serious they
are tragic childhood trauma can affect
every as aspect of a child's life often
following them well into adulthood in
the most devastating cases it leads to
death I poured everything into these
investigations my time my energy and
even my emotional and physical
well-being but despite our best efforts
as Law Enforcement Officers children are
still falling through the cracks time
and time again Law Enforcement Officers
across the state investigate cases of
child neglect that don't meet the
purposeful standard outlined in our
current statutes in these cases we are
left to file a report and pass it along
to an already overworked underresourced
DC a social worker hoping that our
findings will contribute to a civil
resolution under RSA
169c this is simply not enough dcyf
cannot continue to Bear the entire
responsibility of child protection we've
seen time and time again the tragic
consequences of a system stretched too
thin the social workers I work with are
some of the most dedicated and selfless
people I know but they are the first to
admit they cannot do it all we need a
stronger and more effective system I'm
not suggesting that every single case of
child neglect warrants criminal
involvement there are certainly
situations where DCF can and should
provide resources such as parenting
classes or in Home Services however
there are cases where these efforts are
not enough many families are unwilling
to accept help and in these cases we as
law enforcement are left in a
frustrating limbo this isn't just an
issue for me but for law enforcement
officers across New Hampshire who face
the same challenges and frustrations
within their own communities
in recent history the harmony Montgomery
case touched the hearts of every Granite
stator Harmony's life ended tragically
and her case brought to light broader
issues surrounding child neglect and
abuse while hers is a high-profile case
it is not unique I can tell you from
firsthand experience that there are many
children like Harmony children who are
suffering in silence whose situations
have not yet reached a point of a
headline but whose circumstances are
just as Bleak and just as dangerous
these children are living in neglectful
situations with the same potential for
harm but our laws do not law enforcement
the tools to intervene early enough to
prevent that harm after me you're going
to hear testimony from two grand
estaters who have been deeply affected
by child neglect I'll allow them to
speak for themselves however I do want
to relay um how these stories relate to
HB
257 first case involves a child named
Sophia she was 9 years old and she
experienced the most horrific neglect I
have ever witnessed in my career if I
were to describe the details of her case
many of you would find it almost
impossible to believe and you'd likely
be moved to tears Sophia was a frequent
subject of DCF and law enforcement
intervention but the resources available
simply were not enough it became a horse
to water situation where help was
offered but the family refused to accept
it ultimately Sophia was rescued after a
comprehensive multi-disciplinary
investigation but it never needed to get
to that point where that neglect
escalated to serious physical abuse if
we had the tools to intervene earlier
this child could have been spared much
emotional mental and physical trauma
then there's Charlotte tragically in
2023 due to a medical
complication while I was able to show
that her death could have been prevented
we were unable to prove that her
caregivers directly caused that death
however what we could see was that
Charlotte had been neglected leading up
to her death and these patterns were
evident throughout that investigation
sadly we never had received any prior
reports about her however even if we had
under the current laws there would have
been little to no route for law
enforcement
intervention this bill HB 257 offers a
Solution by broadening the standard for
prosecution child neglect cases we can
address cases where neglect is occurring
but doesn't meet that narrow purposeful
threshold it'll provide Law Enforcement
Officers across the state with tools we
need to intervene earlier before neglect
turns into irreversible harm I urge you
to consider the safety and well-being of
the children in our state and take
action to close this Gap in the law our
children deserve more they deserve to be
protected and they deserve a system that
can act before it is too late in closing
I ask that you find this bill ought to
pass pass thank you for your
time thank you Sergeant any questions
representative
n thank you and thank you for taking my
question um I one aspect I think that um
I'd like to at least flesh out is that
uh on the parents part there might be um
an element of um mental health um that
there there might be a a mental health
component to the to the neglect right
and so I'm wondering in your experience
um in dealing with situations like this
is that something that you often find
and would you find even if this law
existed for the standard of of criminal
NE neglect um if there were an element
of uh mental health issues on the
parents part do you would that still be
handled in a different
way thank you for the question I think
that largely depends on what exactly
that mental health issue is obviously in
order for the state to pursue a
prosecution we would still have to prove
that that person is competent to stand
trial um so it it would depend on what
exactly that issue is it's no secret we
have a mental health crisis um in this
state um but that doesn't excuse um some
of the behavior mentioned um in this
statute however um this is also where um
the RSA 169c comes in as my colleagues
had testified earlier so when we talk
about the the Civil resolutions that can
fall into those civil resolutions the
intention of this bill as I said is not
to criminalize everything it's where
appropriate so in certain cases if the
parent has you know whatever that may be
schizophrenia that may be something that
falls more into 169c and DCF offering
involvement and services um this is
meant to address the cases where you
know that's not really effective
absolutely thank you that that's kind of
what I wanted to get to because
regardless you want to address the issue
and and intervene on behalf of the child
right but as a matter of you know
consequence for the parent um I think
that's comforting to know that there are
are different Avenues based on what the
situation is with the thank you thank
question you no further questions thank
good morning my name is Tina Delorenzo
and I'm here with my husband Joel We are
from Claremont New Hampshire and I want
to thank you Mr chairman for allowing me
the opportunity to speak on behalf of my
family and this important bill changing
this law is incredibly important to us
today
sorry on behalf of my beautiful
granddaughter Charlotte Elizabeth
Ward Charlotte tragically passed away on
October 4th 2023 at the age of
five that day my son's life my life and
my husband's life changed forever we are
devastated by this loss Charlotte died
from a condition called toxic Megan
colon due to chronic idio ideopathic
constipation which caused her intestines
to rupture her little body became so
severely backed up that it led to a
fatal condition and she passed away from
the toxins that were released into her
system what makes this tragedy even
harder to Bear is the knowledge that
Charlotte could still be here with us
today if she had received the proper
care and
attention the child's
mother who should have had Charlotte's
best interest at heart failed to provide
the necessary Medical Care Charlotte's
condition was ignored she wasn't taken
to the doctor for necessary appointments
and she wasn't given the proper
medication instead her mother's Focus
seemed to be on her own desires drinking
partying and neglecting her daughter's
well-being the living conditions in her
home were also appalling when police
arrived at her mother's house that day
they condemned the
property there was dog and rat feces
everywhere throughout the house
including Charlotte's bedroom there were
bags and trash bags of trash piled up up
in every room and a dead dog in a crate
basement none of us knew this had cot in
this bad because when we we hadn't been
inside the home for over four years
after my son divorced her
mother as Charlotte lay in the ER I
promised her I would find justice fight
for her
justice her death was preventable and I
vowed that those responsible would be
held accountable but after the police
investigation we learned that this case
fell into a legal gray area it was clear
that Charlotte had been neglected and
that her caregiver had acted NE
negligently even recklessly but not
purposefully even though we could
clearly see that Charlotte's death could
have been prevented the the current law
failed to offer a route for prosecution
sorry the medical nect played a critical
role in her passing but under the
current statutes we are un unable to
prove that her mother caused charlot's
death under any of the homicide statutes
the legal language around purposely
violating a duty of care didn't allow us
to pursue charges even though the
circumstances of Charlotte's death were
directly linked to her mother's neglect
this left us in a position where Justice
could not be served and my granddaughter
I want to be clear this bill will not
bring Justice for
Charlotte but it can help prevent other
families from experience the same
heartbreaking loss I want to ensure that
the next time a child faces neglect or
abuse their parents and grandparents
won't have to face the harsh reality
that the law was not strong enough to
I ask each of you to take a moment and
consider the gravity of this
situation what if it were your child or
before you shared a meal hugged them or
heard their day heard about their day
and then suddenly they were gone never
to feel their little arms around you
again or hear them say I love you again
and what if the person responsible
simply moved on with their life without
consequences please take this bill
seriously change the language and the
law and give us the tools we need to
protect our
children no family should have to live
with the pain of knowing the their
promise to their child went unfulfilled
simply because of two words in the law
thank you for your time and
consideration
lorck good morning thank you my name is
maryan the
rock this bill is important my
granddaughter Sophia was uh rescued from
her house at 9: let me give you a little
backstory she lived with my daughter and
myself until she was four her mother got
arrested we continued to care for her as
her Guardians until she was
six the way the law is written for
biological parents her father got her
who'd never met her but he got
her and then he refused to allow anybody
else in her life so even though I was
calling
DCF every week every month can you do a
well check I haven't heard I I know
things are going on because I hear
rumors from other
people and part of sof's situation was
that um he locked her in her room
screwed the door shut put her in Diapers
at 9: because she couldn't leave the
room to go to the bathroom to leave her
house she had to climb in and out of a
ladder on the second
floor she went to school when he felt
like sending
her she ate when he felt like feeding
her she didn't have clothes for the
weather in this time she ran away 22
times 22 to the police department who
couldn't help her because they had to
bring her home
they'd bring her home and her dad would
come up with some song and dance you
know it's just kids they do this stuff
or they wouldn't answer the door
wouldn't answer the
calls and it just continued to
escalate finally
through numerous calls and the school
intervening because sof went to
school in the dead of winter
inadequately clothed she was wearing I
think she said sandals no jacket and
summer clothes because that's what she
room if any time that she had run away
those 22 times and there's a
seven-year-old walking around the
streets of Newport there was some place
in some law in place that said hey you
know that's not right you should know
what your kids do you should know where
they were and that's not that's not
allowable there were no consequences
well I shouldn't say that he got nine
months because they had to try him as
domestic abuse that was our choice if
we'd have pushed it to be tried as a
child abuse case Sophia would have had
to
testify she'd had enough crap in her
life and so one of the stories she talks
to me while I drive which is probably
for the best because she can't see my
face we're driving one day and she so
Nana she wases you know sheetrock
doesn't taste
good okay how do you know
that oh well I was in my room for a
while and Dad wouldn't feed me so I
tried eating
sheetrock she say doesn't taste good
don't try it like okay so I
don't but I think for I mean she had a
good outcome we they rescued her my
daughter adopted her we removed the
parental rights
but that takes time and in that two and
a half years with her father if month
one month two there' have been something
in place it wouldn't have escalated to
the trauma that she has to live with the
rest of her life she's doing well she's
in counseling but she has to live with
that the rest of her life we need to do
better we need to not have the should of
would a could
us because these little people don't
have the voice and
based on the
stories that were proven were not
stories if a nine-year-old went to
school and said well yeah I have to
climb a ladder to get in and out of my
house you'd think well you know that's a
story you're nine your parents would
never do
that we have to listen better we need to
do
better thank you for your
deoy thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee it's a pleasure to be
before criminal justice than is my first
time before criminal justice so thank
you and it's John dejoy for the record
um I represent the national Association
of Social Workers the New Hampshire
chapter and that's who I'm testifying on
behalf of today the nasw New Hampshire
is the membership Organization for
social workers in the state of New
Hampshire we take on a variety of
licensing and insurance issues as well
as social justice issues Child
Protection is a significant issue that
we've been involved in for many
years as a let me just say as a
grandfather my heart goes out to the um
people have testified today
reminds me of back in 2016 and 2017
after the deaths of brel Gage and sad
Willet I sat on a commission that was um
put forward by Senator
botin looking at the department looking
at the child protection act and looking
at
um how best to protect
children unfortunately the NS you
opposes this bill because we believe
that this issue ought to be under the
child protection act for a couple of
functional
reasons effectively what this Bill runs
the risk of doing is criminalizing
poverty I know it says in the bill that
poverty is not a reason but when
children are living in a car with their
parents because that's all they can
afford or children are only eating at
school not at home because that's all
they can
afford it still appears and in fact is
neglectful simply not willful neglect I
think the other reason is that when
parents do get caught up in the legal
system under this statute where it to
pass most of the parents we're talking
about likely will be represented by a
public defender they will likely plead
to the charges because they're not able
to afford proper
councel so it runs the the risk of the
folks that very folks we're talking
about not having full access to the
system there are significant issues with
the child protection
act um the commission that I mentioned
and I won't get too far a field because
this is not child children and family
law we made numerous changes with the
commission including creating the office
of the child advocate including um
pushing for additional funding and
Staffing for a
DCF but we were styed when we tried to
broaden and strengthen the purpose and
definitions Clause of 169c 169 C2
specifically and what stamed US was case
law New Hampshire case
law um gives deference to
parents the statute we were trying to
craft was to protect
children and while parents rights are
extremely important there is a basic
conflict if the courts give deference to
parents rights especially in these
situations
um it's harder to protect children we
believe the department does have tools
to protect children
more but we also believe that the
department often is understaffed and
underresourced as has been stated today
making this a criminal statute is not
not going to protect more
children it's going to incarcerate
parents many of whom are doing the best
they can some of whom are incapable of
caring for their child but there are
already Provisions in statute to address
parents who are incapable or unwilling
to care for their child the abandonment
statutes termination statutes as we've
heard about and while they're cumbersome
they're cumbersome for a reason our
system of justice
tries to give people the benefit of the
doubt tries to make sure we don't make
rash
judgments my concern with this is that
this will catch up a lot of PE lot of
parents in the criminal justice
system and once you're in and snared in
that
system it is easy for folks of lesser
means to wind up bearing the full brunt
of the
system we would be happy we would
encourage this committee to refer this
to the children and family law committee
I can tell you there is currently a bill
before the children and family law
committee that is addressing the child
protection act there was a statutory
committee that uh concluded last fall
relative to the child protection act and
we will be more than happy to work with
children and family law to work on
filling the um addressing the gaps that
exist in the statute and with that I'll
excuse me representative
n thank you and thank you for taking my
question um I'm curious uh I'm actually
kind well I guess you could call me a
social I work at a transitional family
shelter um so of course I'm a mandated
reporter and things like that um in a
lot of the situations that I've seen um
I think a lot goes
into what is what is causing it right
and so that I think that's really what
I'm trying to get at with the standard
and um you know how we address things
and and maybe address them in different
ways and so my question um you know that
has been what I'm trying to get at um in
my question so far and so I guess to you
my question is do you are you not
satisfied um with the what has already
been clarified um that there would be um
different courses of action based on
different back
patterns thank you representative for
the question and I think you know our
our criminal code our statutes give law
enforcement an incredible amount of
jurisdiction and
discretion that's
appropriate but then we're asking law
enforcement to make a determination of
which parent is neglectful and which
parent is
not in fact the commission I mentioned
before it it formly was police
departments fielded after hours
calls for abuse and neglect reports
that was the way the department dealt
with it before the the
commission that we ask law enforcement
to do a
lot and they do a lot with a little as
well
unless law enforcement has appropriately
trained uh
therapists asking law enforcement to
determine neglect is just a it's beyond
okay representative
Sher have we talked with the uh the
attorneys at the Children's Law Center
uh about this bill I have not I'm simply
representing my
appr I'm kind of baffled by your
testimony that you think it's okay for a
child to sit and wait in neglect and
keep being abused while a cumbersome
system tries to figure it out which from
what I've seen doesn't do a very good
job at
all and now we want to provide law
tool to help save this these
children and you're against it is that
correct
thank you very much for your question
representative and I think you misheard
my
testimony I don't think so we don't as I
said we've been involved in trying to
address the child protection system for
many
years we don't believe that
criminalizing
parents is the way to do that you know
we we formerly criminalized parents and
could have arrested parents for their
kids being
Trent right it's obviously different
still
neglectful
but when families break down it's not
for a single reason it's for many
reasons and yes we have to protect the
children but at the same time we should
not be infringing on the
parents so that's more closely what I
yeah right so who should we be
infringing on if not the parents who are
creating the neglect I'm kind of
confused there thank you for the
question and as I as I mentioned DCF can
do more than they do under
statute
the I I'm I'm struggling representative
because I don't want to testify as
though I'm sitting in front of the
children and family law where I would
get into particulars of the child
protection act that's not what this
committee is doing I just want to make
it clear that while I don't think this
is a criminal justice issue I do think
this is an important issue that needs to
be actively addressed by the children
and family law
committee thank
you is there anyone else wishing to test
find this spill who wasn't oh I'm sorry
ahead something that strikes me in other
other laws where we deal with people in
poverty one of the things that we will
do periodically is write in uh some type
of an exemption or some type of
clarifier uh for example for for people
who are Indigent so if we were to do
this with this particular statute it's
not like giving people a get out of jail
free C but um a directive that uh the
court will take into account in the
economic status of the people I'm not
sure exactly how we would word this uh
but the bottom line is as I can see why
this would be a concern and we we we
don't want to criminalize poverty on the
other hand we don't want to non-criminal
eyesee criminal activ activity which I
think we've heard is going on here so um
I'm just wondering if that if if there
was a way to address that in the
language of the bill would that satisfy
your
concern thank you for the question
representative the devil's always in the
details I think every
nearly all of these criteria under uh
poverty it's not clear to me although I
would NE never foreclose an opportunity
it's not clear to me how you would craft
the language you're you're talking about
but we certainly would be happy to take
a look at that and revise Our Testimony
if that were appropriate given what you
came up with thank
you thank
you is there anyone else wish to testify
in this bill who was not done so please
approach do you have a card for we need
a pink card for you
please thank you Mr chair for the record
state representative hope Damon I serve
half of Sullivan County um I'm here as a
co-sponsor of the bill and
appreciating how complicated the
considerations of our multiple
constituencies are on this I would just
like to say I would like the committee
to
seriously evaluate the language of the
bill and the intent and respect that we
need to do a much better job of
protecting children than what we're
currently doing and while that certainly
should include better access to Social
Work Services my personal belief is
including them in police departments
would be a vast step forward in meeting
families needs
and better funding and services through
DCF in a much more timely manner we
can't wait for that to happen we have to
protect kids today and Mr chair if I may
the um County attorneys would like to
come back and clarify in regards to the
permissible I'm going to appoint a
subcommittee so I don't think it's
necessary we'll we'll hear what they
have to say thank you and thank you all
for your work yeah thank you with that
and no one else wishing to testify um
I'm appointing a subcommittee on this
and I will be chairing the subcommittee
and the members will be representative
Murphy Murray myself and representative
hearing and I open the public hearing on
House Bill for what's
that why
would never mind five minute
break
e
I opening the public hearing on House
Bill 405 and I invite the prime sponsor
approach thank you for the record my
name is Erica Leon I'm a state
representative from Derry entering my
third term uh that's relevant because
all through the time I've been in office
people have been trying to approach deal
with these massage parlors and other
things where it's pretty obvious what's
happening behind closed doors but nobody
has the tools to address it um I know
that many heads are better than one and
many committees are better than one
because I'm now on executive departments
and administration which has dealt with
this process through the licensing and I
know that there are other committees and
other approaches that have tried to look
at the fact that there are places where
everybody knows that sex is being sold
and bought in our State and we can't
touch it with our existing laws I put
together this study committee so that we
can actually get the right people in the
room so that we can have a long longer
and more focused look and figure out how
we can actually find some approaches
that will work and we remove this
problem I I know that just addressing
store Front sex traffic trafficking
doesn't address the entire process and
the entire problem that we have um with
especially the non-consensual purchase
and sale of sex but the does address one
of those areas that impacts places like
my town of dairy we have many many shops
where the windows are covered over
they're supposedly offering services but
you can't actually walk in and make an
appointment and I've had people in the
community tell me that they have gone in
and theyve turned over during a massage
and an area they did not want touched
was touched we need to make sure that
law enforcement and everybody else who
needs to have the tools in order to
address this are able to do so because
this should not be happening so um I
basically I brought this forward and I'm
very happy to see the turnout behind me
I'm simply a vessel to ask you to put
together the study committee and let the
smarter people who can better handle
this situation try and find some
solutions so I'm happy to take any
questions have have you brought anyone
from your law enforcement Community
today to testify um I did not but I know
our Town Administrator is here I know
the chiefs of police are also here um
and I I expect that people would be
coming in for those committees thank you
um representative Ro you had a
question I did thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question you
actually mentioned something that I I
wanted to ask which was in both of our
first terms there was a bill that came
to Ed Edna that they were hoping that
would actually address this sex
trafficking phenomenon and that that
bill was sent to interim stud and then I
believe it just it just died so my
understanding is that this has been
looked at this has been studied I know
the Coalition has done a lot of work on
and the police officers have done hours
and hours and hours so one was what what
exactly are you looking for from the
study committee because if we can
actually just make this be a bill to to
regulate those businesses so the so that
the people can actually get in and do
their jobs and save the people that need
saved could we just do that instead of
wasting more time and not having
anything happen well thank you that's a
very very good question I only been on
Edna for a few weeks I had not been in
the licensing area before however um
when you look at it a lot of people who
are sort of professional law Breakers
know how to skirt up to and right along
the edge of what is legal and what is
not legal um I think that we need to
have not only licensing but we need to
have other people involved in this
because one of the areas that I thought
might work would be to have a solution
where if this is going on and if they
don't if the you can write it into your
lease agreement that if they don't
consent to inspections if it appears
that they may be participating in this
that the landlord can terminate that
lease and so that's something that would
go outside of Edna because the landlords
are often renting space to these
businesses they may not know what's
going on and the leases I I don't
believe they can just kick somebody out
because they don't like the business
that they're doing um a lot of times we
have lease terms I know that's being
heard in judiciary for residential but
for commercial as well especially when
you're investing in building out a
business you're going to expect to be
able to stay there for a certain amount
of time however if you have these these
posters up on your window and up on your
wall even if you're able to skirt any
regulations that we do have on the
licensing side we should also have the
tool of allowing a landlord to terminate
that that lease if they are not going to
submit to searches if there is a strong
expectation that this is what's
happening I want to look at not just one
approach but I want this study committee
to have sort of an all of the above
approach because professional law
Breakers will come right up to that edge
uh they will find the ways to work
around this and we need to have a m
multifactorial approach because just one
approach is just going to have them
shift their business
model thank
you see no further questions thank you
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you to the committee for um hearing my
testimony I am Jody Nelson I represent
uh Derry there are going to be a lot of
people um who will be testifying who
will be giving um you know a lot of
details I'm not going to waste your time
and just with that because I know that
they will be providing you with more
information um I and and maybe ideas
about tools um that we can use to um
help solve this issue I have been uh
working for the past couple of years
with um our town and we did um they did
pass an ordinance they thought would be
able to um at least somewhat fix this
problem and it's just not enough we
really need some sort of um help um on
the on the state level with uh with some
laws uh these people uh in in terms of
your question representative roads
um what I'm finding uh what I'm hearing
is that there are um these folks who
are not only
now
uh being licensed in Body Works which is
what um was concentrated on in the prior
uh bills they're now moving into saying
that they're estheticians and giving
scalp massages and there's one in our
town and also I am hearing that nail
salons are also um providing these um
Services I just find it's extremely um
disturbing we're having human
trafficking in our own towns in New
Hampshire and nobody seems to care about
these women um you know I I drive by I
walk by these shops every day knowing
from all the research that I'm done that
the majority of these people women
working here are trafficked and they
live in these shops they are not allowed
to go out they are afraid because
they're threatened that if they say
anything to police or ask for help
they're going to get in trouble they're
going to be arrested they're going to be
deported or worse I also wanted you to
know that there are some landlords who
absolutely know there is illegal
um operations happening um and these
people frequently pay in cash for a full
year or for the term of their lease so
that's really appealing to some lanlord
and they simply just turn a blind eye I
also wanted to let you know that um I
monitor certain um chat rooms there are
people who go to these places in New
Hampshire and they talk
about sex acts that are performed in
specific locations how much they pay
what the names of the women are um and
something also that we need to talk
about is this is a public health issue
there are sex acts that these people are
describing hundreds and hundreds of
pages I tried actually to figure a way
to share this with you
and even redact trying to redact um
certain portions it was just
inappropriate um you know if you're
interested I'm sure you can find find
them on your own there are acts that are
talked about constantly on these chat
rooms where there is no protection being
used so this is a public health issue
for the partners of these people who are
purchasing illegal sexual acts from
these women and also for the women who
are uh not being protected as well um
thank you I I'll take any questions if
you'd
like see no questions oh representative
Muse um you said that you uh passed an
ordinance in dery to try to deal with
this issue what what did the Ordinance
do um thank you for the question
representative um if if you if I may um
we have our Town Administrator here who
who would be more able to answer more
specifically I just don't want to waste
a lot of your time if that's okay with
you thank you thank you for your
you the chair calls The Honorable
Charles
foot good afternoon chairman Roy members
of the committee thank you for allowing
me to come here and give testimony to
this important topic um so I'm here
representing
der Rockingham County 13 but also I'm a
town counselor and have been for for the
last three terms um for the last seven
years or so I've been working with our
economic development director Bev
Donovan and we've trying to been you
know tackling these and chasing this
thing around um and it appears every
time the town has some kind of footing
to go in and try to um absolve some of
these businesses the ownership changes
every few months they change names they
change locations uh we we have people in
town who help brokering different
locations for them um and as far as
locations I mean we have a couple
literally feet away from town hall we
have one that directly abuts a school
the back the back property line um but
one of these locations they're in uh
locations with reputable businesses
that's bringing down those business
opportunities for those individuals we
have um a lot of uh issues going on with
this I think we currently have not
to give it any uh gloat but we have nine
of these businesses in town currently as
of today and it's not just a dery
problem it's
not just us so if we eradicate this in
Derry they're going to go to the next
town or the next town they're going to
go to your little small town so this is
a literally not just a dairy Town issue
or a Statewide issue this is actually a
national issue this is a there's human
trafficking going on here this is a very
problematic issue um representative
rhods I agree with you I'd be amendable
to having a bill to address this and
finally give some teeth to whatever it
is we need to do to protect these these
individuals um as far as landlords we
have some landlords who are complicit
whether be by being absentee landlord or
by turning a blind eye so this is a a
real problem uh um like representative
Nelson said our town administrators here
and and maybe give you a little more
technical aspect to that but I just want
to come here and Adam ly support this
bill and I would hope that you would
support it as well thank you for your
you um thank you that's thank you the
Karen good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
your time I did submit testimony last
evening I hope you're all received it so
I'll try to just hit the highlights is
that uh as as a counselor and
representative footstep we have about
over a half a doz of the establishments
here through our in Dairy through our R
advertisements and non-conventional
websites we do know what's occurring and
there's got to be more coordination
between the state and communities to
make this work we did pass an ordinance
that ordinance uh has been somewhat
ineffectual uh it did give us the
opportunity to inspect the premises but
the not without notice uh as you know
with with due process so you know the
coordination between the state and the
towns would be critical for this uh we
convened our team in Dar of of our chief
of police our code people Economic
Development and we quickly came up with
a list of 30 suggestions to make help us
make this no longer under the Hampshire
problem among those was think of the
state liquor enforcement will you have
enhanced review of ownership management
location employe employees uh we need to
review and enhance penalties for
violations of trafficking and
prostitution we also need enforce
capabilities to enhance those and
resources at the office for professional
license ear and
certification we also recommend you
eliminate any Reciprocity for licenses
with other states because most of these
problem establishments uh come from out
of state uh and make make no uh make no
mistake there are some long-standing
massage uh uh licensed folks and D
who've been there forever who run
legitimate businesses we also want to
make sure they don't get caught up in
any kind of uh uh legislation what would
really help us because a lot of these
establishments jump from Community to
community is that a Statewide database
of licens applications and employees uh
would really help us in this cause you
know in the past our law enforcement
folks our chief police has been very
active he's been working with the
Department of Homeland Security on a lot
of these issues however what what the
problem is is that these investigations
are lengthy and due to often times
language barriers and the refusal to
coorporate uh from the witnesses and the
victims on both sides we usually don't
make do we usually don't uh result in a
favorable outcome we think a better
approach is to have a very strict
licensing process where you have a
person who is licensed to one particular
location and they have to go back to the
state to get it changed we think that's
going to give us more opportunities to
succeed and make sure that the only
massage establishments established and
operating in the state of New Hampshire
are those legitimate businesses so if I
can offer a suggestion to uh hopefully
improve the bill is I was suggest that
you expand the membership to include
somebody from law enforcement
potentially appointed by the Hampshire
Chiefs of police and also somebody from
the code side either appointed by nhma
or by the New Hampshire building
officials Association I love to be able
to have this problem solved tomorrow but
candidly I think it's more complex we
number one we want to make sure we get
it right and number two that we don't
create hardships for those legitimate
massage businesses which which are
operating throughout the state I'd be
questions go ahead representative
Sal thank you for taking my question um
could be anecdotal but what percentage
of these
workers are illegal
immigrants I don't have information on
question thank
you see no further questions thank you
for your testimony thanks for your time
appreciate
it the chair calls Miss Pamela kig and
good afternoon Mr chair and uh members
of the committee my name is Pamela kyg
and I am the public policy specialist at
the New Hampshire Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence um as you
know the Coalition is the umbrella
Organization for our 12 community- based
crisis centers which provide free and
confidential services to nearly 15,000
survivors of sexual and domestic
violence annually and include um victims
of human trafficking as well um I'm here
to testify on hb45 which seeks to
address um the illicit businesses that
enable sex trafficking to occur in our
state um we thank rep Lon for bringing
this legislation forward and we support
this bill with an amendment ideally um
there have been extensive conversations
about this issue over the past few years
and we asked the committee to um really
take action today I think there you'll
hear several concrete proposals that I
think we can definitely work with you to
ensure that we are finally getting um to
these key issues um previously this
legislation has gone to other committees
as you've heard and we think uh your
committee is particularly poised um from
a public safety lens to really address
um this critical issue and we understand
that you know how Insidious these crimes
are um and how you all are uniquely
positioned to really do something here
today and so we're ready to work with
you um I'm joined with my colleague Meg
chant um who is our program director at
the Coalition um so I'm going to turn it
her good afternoon for the record my
name is Meg chant in my role at uh the
Coalition I serve as the Director of the
New Hampshire human trafficking
collaborative task force which is a
multi-disciplinary partnership between
law enforcement agencies prosecutors
healthc Care Professionals Children's
Services victim services and Community
Partners throughout the state today I'm
here to provide information again
related to hb45 and to support Pamela
with providing some potential policies
that could help enhance our
anti-trafficking work that we're already
doing around the state the reality as
I'm sure most of you know is that there
are many many types of human trafficking
happening here in New Hampshire the task
force has identified trafficking in
every County um age um victims aging
from very small children to the elderly
um both American Nationals and foreign
citizens um the forms of a range from
Forced and coerced agricultural labor to
forced prostitution for several years
the task force has been leading an
effort to combat elicit massage
businesses elicit massage business is a
term that was created by the Polaris
project the national human trafficking
hotline um organization and it describes
a very specific type of exploitative
organized commercial front trafficking
venue that they saw implicated over and
over in cases reported to the hotline
the term does not Encompass legal
therapeutic massage businesses nor does
it include non-coercive sex work that
may incorporate
massage while we're aware that these
businesses exist in our state it's been
very difficult to initiate a human
trafficking investigation in these
situations human trafficking prosecution
relies really heavily on victim input um
and in the absence of a stable secure
victim and by that I mean a victim who
both is and feels safe uh from their
trafficker it's nearly impossible to
gather the information that we need to
bring a case uh we do have members of
law enforcement here with us today who
serve on the human trafficking task
force so they're going to provide
additional information about the
challenges that they face when they're
responding to these
situations um it's a priority of the
Coalition in partnership with the task
force and other stakeholders to connect
as many of these victims and survivors
in these situations as possible with
services that can help raise them out of
Crisis we know that these businesses are
operating around the state and the
victims in these situations are really
carefully controlled and monitored and
they have very little opportunity to
seek help let alone to research what
options might be available to them
traffickers have a massive amount of
control that they exert over these
victims in many elicit businesses the
victims are immigrants to this country
um and traffickers can exploit their
social and cultural norms and their
relative lack of contacts and social
supports and local resource knowledge
here um as well as a fear of removal
from the United States to be able to
keep that victim isolated and compliant
so it's you know there's extra barriers
to some victims in these situations and
also some of them might not speak
English which again is is obviously an
extra barrier traffickers do also tell
victims that seeking services or
reporting to law enforcement would open
them up to prosecution because they're
engaging in prostitution you'll hear
more from our Law Enforcement Officers
about this this is not a priority when
they are um finding victims in these
cases and trying to support them um so
but the trafficker will make it clear
that the only path that they have to
safety is by compliance what with what
the trafficker is demanding um so this
is why we do have a multidisiplinary and
comprehensive approach when it comes to
to these
cases um I think as you've as you've
heard a little bit already and as you
will continue to hear this uh this
afternoon uh we have put significant
resources and expertise into
understanding these issues already um
and I think we already have a good sense
of who all the stakeholders are and what
their input is to solving these issues
um I think you know there are a lot of
folks unfortunately who have had Direct
experiences trying to address this issue
in the state um many national
organizations have also researched this
issue thoroughly um and what we've
identified as some of the best policy
approaches have been heavily vetted and
adopted by other states um so the New
Hampshire legislature has been a leader
in addressing human trafficking in our
state um and this legislature um this is
now an opportunity to not just study um
these illicit businesses but really take
action um because um without action we
continue to see the exploitation of
individuals in our state um we would be
happy to work with the committee to
develop language um based on one of our
our proposals um such as um raising the
penalty for facilitating prostitution in
New Hampshire providing licensing
oversight um to these businesses and
others um that you've heard here today
um we are ready to be a resource and
really hope that you all will consider
um helping us eradicate this problem
from our state um thank you so much and
we're happy to answer any
questions
no thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um my concern is around um uh people who
do have uh potentially a a precarious
documentation situation and so I guess
my question is are there um are there
protections for women who are in this
situation who may not uh be documented I
think the fear of of being removed from
the country is very real do we have
protections around that so people feel
safe uh to be able to come forward yeah
it is absolutely a real fear and you
know the fact that we have it doesn't
mean people know about it um we there is
there is a t visa for victims of human
trafficking um the phrasing of that can
be confusing because it talks about
serious forms of trafficking but the
definition it includes any trafficking
um so that does exist but like you say
it is a barrier for people and I think
uh like Meg shared earlier our primary
goal and why we have a
multi-disciplinary approach in the state
so part of the task force it like Meg
mentioned uh Child Protection Services
it's Advocates at crisis centers its law
enforcement its prosecutors um and so on
um part of that is to really look at
this in a comprehensive and
um victim centered way um to ensure that
people are getting directed to resources
and offenders are being held
accountable I've done some research into
this myself and it is it not true
that these These are being run by large
criminal organizations it's not
necessarily just you know one Madam it
it's organizations and they're taking
these women from countries in Eastern
Europe and Asia and they're bringing
them over here they didn't ask to come
over here and many of them um are under
threat not just of themselves of being
deported because some of them frankly
would be happy to go home but their
families back home are threatened as
well if they cooperate with law
enforcement so it's very difficult to to
reach these these poor people to to help
them because they're under such threats
from such large criminal organizations
has that been your experience as well
yeah and I think our uh law enforcement
experts will be able to speak a little
bit more to what they're seeing directly
in New Hampshire and I think that's why
um there's sort of two different like um
rep Leon mentioned in the beginning um
two having a very comprehensive approach
it's not just a law enforcement response
but a regulatory response as well just
I'll just quickly add to that if I may
it's also you know that's one of the key
things that we focus on as a task force
and prioritizing is meeting the victims
where they are and and following what
they need so you know it may be that one
of our Task Force officers encounters a
victim who's really uncomfortable with
law enforcement they're going to get
them connected with an advocate and
figure out what they need in that
situation it's not well you're with law
enforcement now and that's that's where
you stay I just wonder if we maybe it's
we're talking about um law of supply and
demand and maybe we need to focus a
little bit more on the demand and and
these people that are that are taking
advantage of these these women need to
maybe face a much different pen
thank you for your testimony thank you
very
much well representative Muse you really
got to raise your hand higher thank you
um you had said at the beginning of your
testimony that you supported the bill
with an amendment What specifically
would your Amendment do yeah we are
happy um there's a couple of different
policy proposals that have been
introduced in the past and have been
discussed with experts um um so we are
kind of looking to see what the
committee is amendable to do we think
that this is a huge issue and it
definitely merits the attention that
it's receiving um but I think we have
some concrete actions that we can take
today like I mentioned um potentially
looking at the penalties um other states
have lower penalties and that's allowed
New Hampshire to be sort of an open
doormat oh sorry higher penalties so
that's allowed um New Hampshire to kind
of be an open doormat for some of these
businesses um but also um the the
regulatory processes um so that we can
identify and respond in a more timely
manner as you heard criminal
investigations often take a long period
of time and so that's why having these
helpful thank you so much the chair um
can you guys hear us good afternoon my
name is Eric Malera I'm a task force
officer with Homeland Security
investigations in Manchester New
Hampshire I'm also a deputy sheriff of
the straford County Sheriff's Office
part of the investigations unit and I'm
assigned to Homeland Security as part of
the human trafficking task force with
Dave
McCormack my name is Dave McCormack I'm
a task force officer with us Department
of Homeland security I'm also an
auxiliary trooper with the New Hampshire
State Police that's after doing 32 years
with the state police I retired as a
lieutenant running the intelligence
unit um I've been on the task force for
six years since
2019 and that's my background and we're
here today to mirror what the Coalition
said um we don't think there needs to be
a study we just think that we have
enough information to do some some
actionable things today um I think
licensing is hug huge I think
um I think having uh laws in place that
would maybe put these people in fear of
uh opening an illegal massage type
business um some of the things we see is
States you know next to us have made it
a felony to operate a house of
prostitution and that caused a lot of
those to pack up and cross the border
where it's just a misdemeanor um because
this is obviously a a a huge issue um if
we could mirror some of these it would
it would it would make it more difficult
um for them to open up and the the
penalty would obviously be more severe
too so um the licensing I think that
would help us um make these businesses
more legitimate um we have been taking
complaints from Chiefs of police across
the state for the last few years um
we've spent countless hours outside of
massage parlors um it is a very was a
very tough um investigation to crack and
at the end of the day it would just end
up being a misdemeanor most likely um we
take the approach that these women are
victims so our first approach wouldn't
be to go in there and look at them as
you know a sex worker and charge them
with a prostitution charge because again
these are trafficking victims the
majority of them don't want to be there
they're forced there either to pay back
a debt or somewhat against their will um
they're terrified of law enforcement
they're terrified to be um deported
again we try to explain to them if
they'll even cooperate with us that we
can issue or assist them with FASTT
tracking a t visa so they could get
citizenship but even that alone isn't
enough um some of these other women are
trauma bonded to their traffickers where
they think that they're being taken care
of they think that they're doing a
service for this they think that you
know this person loves them um as far as
the Asian massage
parlors that's a little different um
these women typically are there to pay a
debt it's like a highin revolving credit
card that debt will never get paid off
which causes that supply and demand if
they weren't there doing it people
wouldn't be lined up to go there again
um if you did something with the
licensing if you did something um I know
the town of the Derry wants you know
wants them all out but like they said
they can't just Kick the Can there is so
much money involved in this organization
that they'll just pack up and they'll go
to the next town and they'll open up a
new space B um the amount of money that
this brings in um is so high that if we
do find them administratively through
Homeland Security they'll just hand you
thousands of dollars and say thank you
um when we go to try to interview these
women they'll just say that they don't
speak English they cycle in about every
10 days and they all come from an area
of New York and they go up and down the
Eastern Seaboard and we could probably
teach a class on this for an hour and I
know that your time is important we're
happy to answer any questions um
specific questions anything throughout
the state we've we've assisted many
agencies throughout the state with these
problems um and I think they look at us
like we should just be able to go in
there and shut them down but that's not
do can you tell me how involved has the
um the local US attorney's office been
uh I mean is have they been focused on
this problem in Hampshire they have been
we've got we've got um complaints
directly from them um we've had
complaints directly from police Chiefs
and residents um people have called the
hotline people have called this directly
uh the issue is um proving what's
actually going on behind closed doors um
again there's plenty of online resources
that will tell you who's doing what
where they're doing it but actually
getting in there and uh proving a case
tends to be extremely lengthy and
difficult um I think a better route
would just to prevent them from being
there in the first first place sure um
have you had any success at all as far
as um Prosecuting customers who are
actually utilizing these these services
so one thing I recommend to the local
agencies to try to be a thorn in the
side is what we call as John stops and
essentially you'll wait wait outside and
when a customer leaves if they have a
violation youd pull them over and you'd
speak to them about what they just did
inside there the majority of them will
admit that you know they got something
um as far as a prostitution you know
charge I don't see a lot of towns doing
that to their
residents final question for me this
this sounds I mean from what you've
described and what I I know this sounds
like it should be a RICO case all day
long with them moving up and down the
coast and what about the US attorney
them themselves the Attorney General
have they been involved in this has
there been any it seems like the awesome
power that we often complain from the
federal government would be great if
they'd use it here so one of our
colleagues worked a case I think it was
about two or three years he worked this
it was Multistate um New York Boston um
it took years to do and it was a Reco
case and they had great success with it
um and then fast forward tried to work a
similar case I think he took was it500
or $800,000 cash um from this from this
uh massage parlor business um um and
then the court said there wasn't enough
evidence and we had to give it right
back um it is very tough to prove
because again you need cooperation from
the witness and you need evidence
against the owner now the owner
typically says I don't know what's going
on when I'm not here I tell them no no
funny business and the women who in our
eyes are victims will just tell you that
they don't speak English and then within
10 days they're gone you have mandarin
officers or
translators it it would wouldn't even
matter because they're not going to
cooperate represent
Shear uh how does Federal immigration
law if at all uh treat undocumented
individuals who are victims of crimes
like uh the uh victims uh we don't we
don't look at anybody's we look at them
as victims whether they're you know
undocumented or residents we look at
them as victims um we're not political
organization we don't we don't look at
Politics as that we look at these women
as victims whether they're residents or
not and we'll get them the assistance
they need no matter where they came from
um if they're not here legally we can
offer them assistance to be legal um a
lot of the times that's what will build
that Rapport that's what will make them
comfortable um to work with us but it it
is it is rare that um that they'll
cooperate the government does offer a a
Visa specifically for victims of crimes
Visa a t visa trafficing visa
trafficking Visa thank you
representative sh you had a followup uh
no you asked it oh very good thank you
um representative
Newman I had difficulty hearing your
very first part of your testimony and I
thought I heard something about you do
not recommend the study committee or you
do I could you clarify that yeah we're
mirroring them where we don't we don't
think it needs to be studied we know
everything about this we we need
action we need to we need to change some
laws to to to make this easier to
prosecute thank
you thank you um so no further questions
thank you for your testimony I will be
um appointing a subcommittee on this as
well if you'd be willing to work with
them thank you thank you rep uh the
gay I'm just gonna speak I'm just going
to speak as a citizen who until a few
years ago was totally unaware that
prostitution was taking place I just
thought that was in big cities where
there were syndicates of crime I didn't
realize they're in all our towns and
then the movie uh sound of
Freedom was probably the best message
for the public uh one of the Angel
movies and it really spells out that
this is sex trafficking not just of
women who people like to say well they
chose to be in that business I'm very
happy to know that our professionals
know it's not a choice even for the
people who think that it's a choice
Americans not people who were uh
kidnapped when you find out there are
books written by the people who are
running the businesses on how to
manipulate um emotionally pliable women
who think that these guys really love
them and they come from a background
where they're desperate to be loved and
then they it's it's as strong a bond as
as a chain it takes a lot of effort for
them to heal and understand that they
are being treated as victims and they
can get out but then it's even more
devastating to know that they are
children
who are trapped in
this it just makes it if if it wasn't
already bad enough it's a thousand times
worse to know that there are children
who are are sex victims and they don't
have a way
out uh and they're brainwashed that
there is no way out and just like the
women who are from other countries even
if they could get out they're scared
that the that they'll be uh sent back or
their families will be
so I'm with the I'm with the federales
behind me I'm already for some laws how
late can a law be submitted now this
session it's already too late to submit
new legislation I thought that there was
a an another another
category we can amend or we could make a
non-gain amendment to new but there's
many methods to oh so there is a way but
not not introducing it as a new law
right right but there are ways to do it
well I would really recommend that so
much expertise now has been said to you
guys that I didn't say y'all okay so
much expertise has already been spoken
here you have so much information even
if you can't write the total
encompassing book uh law that would
touch all the ills it would be great to
write the most to uh pass the one it
would give some immediate
tools that would be very oh and keep
studying it though do pass the bill as
it is too because we do need much more
comprehensive treatment and uh that's
the opening the door but let's open the
door and put a bill through um an
amendment so that our enforcement people
have some tools to start addressing
these criminals
thank you
representative thank you thank you is
there anyone else wishing to testify in
this bill who hasn't signed up to
testify seeing none I hereby close the
public hearing on House Bill
405 we will reconvene at 1:30 to take up
House Bill
416 oh and there will be a subcommittee
on this bill the on House Bill 405 I
will be chair the representative rhs
representative nle representative Murray
and we will probably me meeting next
know
e
I here I open the public hearing on
House Bill
416 and invite The Honorable Rosemary
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for the record my name is
Rosemary rung I'm a representative of
Hillsboro 12 which is the town of
miramac and I got to tell you it's a
real treat to be in front of Criminal
Justice this is my first bill and I
think all the other committees I've I've
presented to I've bored them silly about
cyanobacteria Bloom so it's your turn
now um but uh as many of you aware the
prevailance and uh of toxic
cyanobacteria blooms in New Hampshire
Lakes is a growing
problem um it threatens not only the
health of people and animals but also
our robust Lake economy last year the
occurrence and duration of blooms were
the worst on record and this summer is
predicted to be as bad or Worse the
trend of increasing water temperatures
is the fundamental cause of toxic blooms
both here in New Hampshire and
globally but there are many actions we
can take to reduce the nutrients that
feed cyano bacteria blooms specifically
nitrogen and phosphorus HP
416 addresses one of these actions by
prohibiting the intentional disposal of
yard waste into New Hampshire Waters
this practice is not common among
Lakefront owners but it does occur and
it contributes to the nutrient load that
our Lakes can no longer tolerate it is
important that it be specifically stated
in statute as a violation of the New
Hampshire clean Lakes program not only
will it help reduce the addition of
nutrients to our Lakes but as
importantly it will Foster a culture of
Lake stewardship that everyone has an
individual responsibility to treat our
public resources
responsibly government cannot solve this
problem of toxic cyanobacteria blooms
alone this bill will put up guard rails
so to speak guard rails and speed limits
to establish what responsible behaviors
are when AB budding or accessing New
Hampshire Lakes now what I think the
reason why this bill came to criminal
justice is that there is a fine
component comp comp component and um
enforce by quote peace officers that
language of Peace Officers already
exists within the clean Lakes program
and and the drafting attorney had
Incorporated it in this but I do want to
let the committee know that I am open to
um submitting an amendment if that
language is problematic for you um my
primary goal in this bill is to make
sure that when people do dispose of of
yard waste in Lakes um that they
recognize that that's an illegal
activity and it's not something to be
supported um it also empowers Lake
Associations and Watershed associations
to step in to counsel Lakefront owners
and contractors to the to let them know
that that practice is against New
Hampshire law and with that I would be
happy to answer any
questions thank you could you um could
you tell me what what it would look like
what does an act like this look like is
it someone who's fertilized a lawn and
they're too close to the lake so runoff
happens or are they actually putting
stuff in the lake they're actually
putting stuff in the lake um and it it's
very common in the spring uh when people
who are returning to their seasonal
homes are clearing off leaves and the
leaf blower it's just it's very easy
it's a lot easier than hiring a
contractor or taking it and Hauling It
Off or composting it it's just really
easy to just blow it into the lake and
those leaves and things that have been
on LA on their lawn have probably picked
up whatever they sprayed on their lawn
what makes that difference in the leaves
that fall on from the tree right into
the water that's right okay no that's a
good question well Mother Nature can
handle naturally natural additions to um
the Lakes um and we do have regulations
that restrict the use of fertilizers
within that Shoreline protection Zone
but this and even if a a Lawn isn't
treated or there no pesticides or
fertilizers just the organic um
components of that yard debris going
into the lake contain nitrogen and
phosphorus and they settle to the
sediment to the bottom of the lake and
as they disintegrate they um they make
nitrogen and phosphorus available and
that's what cyanobac cyanobacteria uses
um as nutrients and also um you know
just the the the debris that's been
there over decades centuries um that
will release under certain conditions it
it it can that release of nitrogen and
phosphorus can be catalyzed when the the
bottom layer of water in a lake becomes
anoxic or it it lacks oxygen
and it's just we really can't control
the temperature of of the lakes and
that's this is a global issue but we
really need to work hard and people need
to develop that um
responsibility that not to introduce
something into a lake that mother nature
hasn't intended for it to for it to go
so in other words we can't necessarily
fix the problem but there's no need for
us to contribute to making it worse
exactly and that's what this bill does
and there is things in the shoreline
water quality protection act which
outlines other behaviors that are
prohibited like clear cutting trees um
on a shoreline because th that's very
important to keep trees there one is
they uptake nitrogen and fertilizer for
their own growth but they also prevent
runoff and erosion and um and there's
other like fertilizer application is
also in that act but there's nothing
about about yard waste and it it seems
kind of minimal but it is a it is a
practice that need people need to know
that that's not permitted thank you
further questions from the committee
um representative uh I'm sorry but Sabor
is that close sh thank you sir that was
correct yes um question do we know what
percentage of the phosphorus and the
nitrogen getting dumped in of the total
do you know what percentage of that this
contributed from dumping exactly no I
don't believe it there's been any
studies on that it's it's actually a
behavior that people are pretty discreet
about because I think innately they know
that it's not something they should be
doing they should be hauling it off um
but and and also the amount it's it's
each lake and river is very unique and
there may be some that have high
nitrogen and phosphorate that that come
from the sediment there it there may be
some that's coming from um failed septic
systems so being able to know the amount
of nitrogen and phosphorus that's being
introduced through those individual
activities is really difficult to
measure um and as far as what their
impact would be um you know there in
some Lakes um uh runoff is the number
one issue and this you know something
like yard debris might be number 10th on
the list um but there's some Lakes where
septics systems could be the number one
contributor so it's really difficult to
say how much of the yard debris is
entering the lake but also how much of
an impact that whatever is is making
because that the impact is what would
vary thank you thank you I hope I
answered your question okay thanks
representa
Muse a quick question are there are
there similar things in statute that we
may already be doing that are analogous
to what you're trying to do here yeah so
in the shoreline water quality
protection act um there there are
definitely like the cutting of trees
there's actually a pretty um extensive
formula for calculating what trees you
can cut as far as the diameter uh or the
circumference and the number per square
foot I forget there's a there's a pretty
lengthy um calculation and then um there
there is regulations on the application
of fertilizers
um but there's um you know there's
there's people here from Dees too that
would probably know those off the top of
question represent
Murphy thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question can you tell what
was the impetus for you to sponsor this
bill was there a particular need or did
you see something that someone came to
me and said we need a law I'm sure
people have come to each of you and said
we need this law and um he was very
frustrated with the pra seeing he lives
on a lake and he was very frustrated
seeing people doing this and I you know
filed it away where we file things like
that in our head and then I was at um I
have a seasonal Cottage on a lake and
one day I saw like this island of leaves
go by and I realized that's not from a
leaves falling from a tree and
and and then just observing the severity
in so many lakes last summer of the
blooms you know we need to do whatever
we can even though this isn't a
significant contributor to nitrogen and
phosphorus our Lakes it's it's one thing
we can do to decrease it and more
importantly Foster a culture of
individual responsibility where people
know what is allowed and what isn't
allowed and hopefully it makes them more
aware of how important it is not to put
anything into a lake that mother nature
didn't intend to be
pette thank you thank you just follow up
do do you uh do you think that citizens
of New Hampshire know that doing this is
wrong I think many don't um I also think
it it may not necessarily just be New
Hampshire residents it's people who live
out of state that just come up here
seasonally that are preparing their
properties for the summer um they may
not be aware of New Hampshire laws the
way Granite Staters might be um and
that's the other nice thing about this
is um about putting it in statute is
that local PE local Lake Associations
and Watershed associations can
communicate this to their members and
their neighbors and let them know you
know you're not allowed to do that
anymore because right now they can do
that and um there is indeed yes I think
um you'll get a letter you may have
already received a letter from
commissioner Scott that's saying oh well
this is already in statute but if you
actually go to that statute it's under
water
pollution um they talk about the um you
can't put trees or parts thereof and it
and and that's at the end of a say it
says um uh it talks about disposal
including but not limiting limited to
bottles glass Crocker y cans scrap metal
junk paper garbage tires old automobiles
are Parts thereof trees are Parts
thereof and so it's not a prominent part
of Statute and it's um and so this bill
is trying to make that activity more
explicit and more inclusive of those
types of things someone would put into a
lake you know it's not just a tree or
part of a tree it's saying yard debris
people know what yard debris is um right
now people could think oh I can't put a
tree in a lake well most people don't
put a tree in a lake but boy they'll put
a lot of leaves in in a
lake trees actually provide great
structure for bass
yeah um representative
pette thanks for taking my question um I
was just wondering you said most people
are doing this discreetly so how would
something like this ultimately do you
see something like this being
enforced well I'll tell you there'll be
there's people on the lake who really
have a strong sense of responsibility to
conservation and to re and especially
reducing the contributors to
cyanobacteria blooms they will let them
know um that's where most compliance of
the law occurs is Lake Associations
neighbors um really educating other
neighbors you really you really can't do
that I know you've been doing it um but
did you know that it's now against the
law really something as simple as like
that it can be very successful in
curtailing Behavior just like the the
you know part of the the statute that
prohibits cutting of certain uh number
of trees that's the the education
component of having that in statute and
educating people about that probably is
more successful than anything in
thank you for hearing my testimony I'm
Bria arbiton from New Hampshire Lakes
I'm the director of programs there new
hampsh and thank you again for hearing
my testimony New Hampshire Lakes is a
Statewide nonprofit for the restoration
and protection of New Hampshire's lakes
and it's our first time being in front
of you as well um we support the intent
of this bill to to prohibit yard waste
being disposed of in our state's
Waters and I'm not going to go over too
much more other than from what Rosemary
wrong said she gave you a pretty
comprehensive overview of everything
that we we also agree with
so I can take any questions if you have
any seeing as your um organization is
involved with lakes lake wide have you
had any anecdotal evidence of a lot of
this starting to happen in conjunction
blooms uh so can
you we so as an organization we
represent over 275 associations across
the state Lake Associations across the
state and we do know that this like
we've heard from our supporters that
this does happen people do dump or uh
mow grass clippings into the lake and
yard waste and that stuff
so as as far as anec anecdotal evidence
that algae blooms or cynobacteria blooms
are being uh created from yard waste I
think Dees would be better to give you
that kind of evidence thank you any
further questions representative
emercy I certainly understand the
educational component of this um what I
find difficult is the enforcement of
it um without the testimony or without
somebody actually going in and
testifying for law enforcement how do
you get a conviction on
this that is a great question uh I think
like I said New Hampshire Lake supports
the intent of the bill and as far as how
the enforcement happens there uh like
Rosemary representative run
said other property owners and
homeowners around the lake feel very
so neighborly conversations definitely
help uh promote that the fostering uh of
Lake protection and then actual
enforcement I mean that's I'm not sure I
can adequately answer your
question thank you did you want to
follow up or you good no okay um anyone
else seeing no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank
for the record my name is Ted deers I am
the assistant director of The Water
Division at the New Hampshire Department
of Environmental Services and I'm joined
by Dave Neils who is the head of our
watershed management Bureau and a lake
ecologist a limnologist and he'll be
here here for any science questions that
may come up by the committee uh and I
think that like the trend of previous
speakers uh this is another box I get to
check off of my house committee bingo
card uh being in front of Criminal
Justice so thank you so much uh for
allowing us to do this this is great so
U I think that a lot has been said and I
think representative Rong uh outlined
the the issues
clearly we would maintain our position
at Dees is that this is already legal
under state law law uh that was quoted
before RSA 45
a15 but I would also agree uh with
representative rung that this the
language in that is is peculiar to I
think the era in which that language was
developed and so it may not reflect uh
the current state of affairs of uh of
2025 in which how people deal with their
lawns and the uh the way that they deal
with stuff we do periodically get
complaints uh about this kind of ity at
Dees we generally when we get a
complaint like that and and and by far
the places where we find that there
violations of water quality standards or
other kinds of violations of law come in
through complaints because we we don't
we don't have the staff to go to a
thousand lakes we have a thousand lakes
in the state more or less Dave will
correct me but um and so we don't have
staff to go to a thousand lakes so we do
hear from residents and so our approach
is almost always to call the person
uh who you know has been witnessed doing
something and that could be you know
somebody who's uh withdrawing water um
in a place where they shouldn't be or
somebody who's cleaning out their
Landscaping truck at a fishing game uh
boat put in uh that happens uh with some
frequency we have other things like like
this in which somebody is I think
egregiously uh taking a very large lawn
all the clippings and dumping them you
know uh in the water or other places
nearby the water where they will reach
the water we get these these kind of
complaints a lot and almost what we what
we do is we call the person and go chat
with them because I think that generally
speaking people are not aware and
they're certainly we make them aware
that it if something's against the law
and that uh we also try to make them
aware that other people are watching uh
and and that certainly is the case on
lakes and if you have a place on a lake
you know that people are
watching there's probably several places
in state law where this kind
of that this is addressed in some manner
um and one of the other places is within
our Wetlands laws because these uh the
materials that maybe somebody's putting
in the lake has the potential to then
settle that would actually be filling a
wetland so there are so that that is
also a component of this though somebody
may not realize that necessarily by
reading our Wetlands laws that may this
idea that yard waste is contributing to
that may not be may not be clear we also
have our water quality standards which
is uh which is our which is an EnV WQ
1700 those are our water quality
standards for the state they also
indicate that you can't uh fill the
benthos that is you cannot Place
materials in that will settle and then
fill in the bottom of a a Waterway of
the state so I would suggest that I
think this bill has some Merit the
concept has some Merit to clarify what
people can and can't do on their uh
within the the Waters of the
state however I think that there
probably could be some additional work
to find the right place in law for this
um and then to make sure that it sort of
lines up with other sort of of the fine
rules or fine that are established in
statute already for similar kinds of
violations so I think that there's some
room to be able to maneuver to to
improve uh this um
Bill and with that Dave should I say
anything else about lakes or anything
got all right so with that I will just
um see if you have any uh any questions
and we'll see what we can do so would
you be um amendable to working with the
prime sponsor to maybe getting because
we would be open to an amendment that
put it where you thinks it it needs to
go um or whatever changes you think yeah
absolutely in fact we had that
conversation this morning uh after uh a
different bill in rr&d this morning so
we already had that conversation okay so
uh representative Rong I'll hold on to
this if you want to come back with an
amendment um we'll be willing to do that
um my next question is by far and a way
the most important what effect does Sino
bacteria have on largemouth bass that's
a really good question that I'm going to
give to our our resident ich
theologist ich theologist Lake e colist
I'll do whatever um so I don't think
there's a a real good answer as to the
direct effect on on large mount pass um
but certainly can impact your ability to
enjoy your um you know your recreational
opportunity to uh fish for for large
amount of bass so um we've seen over the
past two years about 120 CYO bacteria
warnings that we've issued on our lakes
around the state of New Hampshire and
they've been everywhere including the
largest lake lake wnab basaki is 44,000
Acres um and it really can prevent the
ability for people to enjoy the
recreational opportunity we don't tell
people they can't do certain activities
but certainly you would would enjoy
fishing for your large mouth bass as
much as you would um if the if the water
were clear and certainly there are
potential uh food web impacts
okay oh yeah I can uh yeah um as Ted
mentioned we we have over the past two
years um encountered and uh been able to
detect a new invasive species in uh Lake
winaki it's the spiny water
flea um that's probably introduced by us
humans but um it can promote cyob
bacteria because it grazes on zanon so
once you remove the zop Plankton that
typically Grays on the algae that are
there it sort of releases that food food
web check and provides an opportunity
breaks the food chain and it it can
disrupt the food chain yes okay has the
have the temperatures of the Lakes been
um rising and at what level over the
last few years we have seen uh a fairly
dramatic shift in the change in the
temperature of the Lakes I can't tell
exactly what that is yeah um we're
seeing very uh much later ice inss and
much earlier ice outs I know this year
and today in particular probably doesn't
seem that way to you um but but last
year um we documented a fairly uh
substantial spike in the water
temperature in Lake basaki and if you
remember it re really never iced in at
all last year so we are seeing that um
across the across the state the the
changes in water and we do have good
documentation of the ice in and ice
outdates thank you all right thank you
any other questions yes representative
n y thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I so in the way that
you're describing um how you would
address a situation where uh it was
reported that someone was putting yard
waste into um the surface waters so uh
my question is or the way that you're
describing that is kind of reactive
right and so in that situation you would
say okay now we we understand that we're
going to reach out we're going to make
you aware um and my question is are
there more preventative measures what is
the level of kind of educating people um
so that they know uh that this is not
okay to do especially I can see that
being an issue with folks coming from
out ofate and just coming seasonally so
thank you representative it's a it's a
great question and I would just point I
would just say that this is one of the
places in which we're very pleased to
have really excellent
Partners uh you know folks like New
Hampshire Lakes folks like the Lake
sunap Association like Paka L pakway
Lake protective Association uh winnipauk
Alliance I could go on and on about the
really uh excellent work that's going on
by both volunteers and professionals to
do that sort of thing we try very hard
to do public Outreach with the tools
that we have uh available to us but I
would just say that that's really the
benefit of having great Partners is so
that people can understand we I think
you heard from New Hampshire lakes that
they have 275 different Lake
Associations that they're in pretty
constant contact with um they also have
a very large list of people in New
Hampshire that they send out stuff to I
know I get their stuff uh several times
a week I think so they're very on top of
doing that kind of activity and they
have and and other people have
other other other groups have specific
Outreach that they do to Lake owners in
particular um one thing that I would
highlight from New Hampshire Lakes is
their lak smart program which works
directly with Lakefront water o uh
Waterfront owners to actually go through
and do an assessment of their property
to identify the pollution sources and
what they can do about it we've done
some of that uh with our soak up the
rain program where we've helped
communities and organizations to create
rain Gardens uh which are a way of
controlling storm water I guess just a
word on pollution in general while I I
have your attention for a moment is that
um New Hampshire generally has excellent
water quality and we are very blessed by
that when you look at compared New
Hampshire Waters to other places in in
the United States and the world we have
really good water quality except where
we don't and where we don't it is almost
always a problem of storm water that is
Storm water's bringing stuff in whether
it's lawn waste or it's or it's
fertilizers or it's other things that
have been put on the on the ground that
is by and large the biggest issue facing
our our our Waters today and so I just
want to just make that note as you think
about uh when this issue comes up about
uh you know lakes and cyanobacteria it
really comes back to those
issues representative Murphy thank you
Mr chair um I have both a comment and a
question um I serve on a on a commission
the environmentally triggered uh chronic
illness here and um one of the issues
and this is to um representative Roy's
points about um fish one of the other um
concerns that we have are the health
impacts known to be Associated um
Associated at this point with um
exposure to cyanobacteria and Dr STL at
Dartmouth um is done a lot of research
into the association with ALS um in
people uh living near I think it was
maybe it was Moma Lake was it um so
there are certainly you know research
takes a while and um I think our our the
concern is always Public Health as well
as you know Lake life and Etc um and in
addition I I um I appreciate the
suggestion that you made to maybe
consider this also for um in relation to
other statute but is there a reason why
it would not be appropriate in the Clean
Lake I I think it's just the the
challenge there is that it's it's a
little bit out of place um most of our
enforcement capabilities occur in other
statutes namely
485a and the way that it's put in is
it's a little bit confusing so I think
that it can be spruced up and where this
ends up in state in state law is one of
those things that we should probably
talk through follow up thank you um what
the there's another list of the things
that are precluded how is that be
different how would the the yard debris
be different than
trees yes thank you for the two
different statutes okay um the the
statute that this is put into is largely
pertains at this point it's the clean
Lakes program which is makes sense why
this would go there don't don't get me
wrong but that largely pertains to
invasive uh species going into the water
so this is the mil foil issue and so
that's largely where has stood it also
does have some of the cyanobacteria
pieces so I think it requires some
consideration about the best place in
state law for it not that it wouldn't
that that this would be horrible If This
Were to passed today it's not going to
you know cause mass chaos but it it
could be better placed to be able to be
more
effective okay so there'll be no harm to
putting it in that I don't think there's
a harm it's just I I just think it it
doesn't line up terrifically with the
rest of what we do okay thank thank you
sure representative L
cell thank you for taking my question
with respect to enforcement does uh
fishing game have any uh enforcement uh
capability or responsibility with this
sort of thing thank you for your
question my understanding is that they
I've not ever seen that um they would
probably bring something to our
attention to to then apply our statutes
under unless it was direct ly affecting
maybe a fish or
Wildlife perhaps but I I don't know the
answer to that question my experience is
that these kinds of things are normally
referred to
us followup follow up it would just seem
to me that fishion game has a a presence
on the Lakes they could possibly witness
someone doing this and just as an
education component tell them that hey
they shouldn't be doing that that sort
of thing yeah I thank you for the
follow-up question I think one one piece
of this piece of legislation is it does
allow for any peace officer okay to be
able to do this I imagine that that
would have inrud Marine Patrol maybe
cosos I don't know how that's all
designated in state law but one of the
things I just point out about the par
this particular law is that it does then
allow for M
municipalities to then have some ability
to be able to um to do something about
this issue should they find out about it
that seemed like a good part of the bill
like that seems like an interesting
thing to me because again mun
municipalities are much more aware of
what's going on in their own communities
and they're as likely as Dees to get a
complaint I think um the
representative's point is well taken
though an interface with Fish and Game
actually as a force multiplier because
they in turn have tens of thousands of
Anglers and Sportsmen and Sports women
who are out there in the water who are
seeing things and are reporting and can
come back and help so I think there's a
partnership to be had yeah we can always
chat with them absolutely okay any
further questions uh representative U
Muse also noting that under uh uh 487 um
one of the things we actually do have in
place is a section on enforcement
Provisions uh for disposal of sewage
from boats right uh and uh if you think
about it I mean this is not quite the
same thing but it's very similar uh um
so I guess my question is could that be
uh you know provide some guidance in
terms of how we go about enforcing this
sure thank you very much for the
question and I think you're right I
think we would look at all those things
if we were gonna you know take another
look at this great thank
you representative um sour d Shire
sh the new species of the invasive
species of flea does that have any
natural predators that could be
um thank you for your question the
question was are there any predators of
the spining waterflea yes that that
could be follow um none that none that
we're aware of uh fish will occasionally
eat them they're uh a very crunchy
morsel to eat so they tend to prefer
other things okay and uh followup
followup follow um the this bill
presents a punitive measure is there a
scientific solution based off of
chemistry that to be used to solve the
blooms there's no chemical solution to
uh reduce the amount of nutrients going
into our water bodies now thank
you where do these fleas come
from great question um they uh are in
Lake Champlain so you know there's a
good chance that they came one of the
larger water bodies Great Lakes Lake
Champlain so it's Vermont's fall of
course yeah we could Point them finger I
suspect it as much thank you for your
testimony it's anyone else wishing to
testify in this bill who has not filled
out a card seeing none I hereby close
the public
hearing and we are going to just take
hearing
for
e
I am here by opening the public hearing
on House
Bill 1
191 and I invite the prime sponsor to
introduce
Bill U thank you very much Mr chairman
and committee members it's a pleasure to
be before criminal justice I think for
the first time uh for the record my name
is Glenn cordelli and I represent
Tuftonboro wolfboro and oopy in the
beautiful Lakes
Region and um Mr chairman I would like
to offer an amendment while I present
this bill um May I pass it out
now and is this amendment meant to
you'll note that it replaces sections
one and two in the wisdom of um OS uh
there's only three sections to the bill
and the third section that is not
included in the amendment is just the
effective
date um so thank you again uh the main
goals of this this bill uh really are
not changed by the amendment which is
number
0035 this bill is about four things and
four things only it's about parents
rights
Predators sex
traffickers and protecting minor
girls an adult who prays in a young and
unemancipated girl will now be committed
if a committing a crime if they One
Transport that girl for the purpose of
concealing or procuring an act def
finded an as an abortion under our state
laws or two obtains an abortion inducing
drug for an act as defined as an
abortion under the state law two facts
to keep in mind the girl is an un
emancipated minor and there is no
permission from the parents
this is targeted at that adult who
performs one of these acts without the
express permission of the girl's parents
and who Could That adult
be well he could be a predator maybe a
family friend maybe a relative even the
adult might be a sex
trafficker this is this anti-trafficking
measure and if you think there is no
trafficking in New Hampshire let me uh
read from several documents for you you
uh this is from the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence we know that human labor and
sex trafficking is a growing problem in
this country and New Hampshire is not
immune increasing awareness of these
crimes result in more positive
identification of human trafficking and
New Hampshire has seen an increasing
number of human trafficking cases in
recent
years this is from the New Hampshire
human trafficking collaborative task
force their 19 excuse me their 2022
annual
report 84 total active investigations in
2022 17 confirmed victims in the first
half and 18 in the second half of the
year it's confirmed that over the past
year 90% of the victims were involved in
sex
trafficking 19 of the 30 confirmed cases
were a minor under age
18 the New Hampshire division of
children youth and
families uh noted that 95 reports were
made to Central intake specific to human
trafficking and related to sex
trafficking were 98% of those
calls and 48% were for girls between the
ages of 15 to 17
DCF provided an additional
244 consults to service providers across
the state who had identified high-risk
children for human trafficking concerns
throughout the ongoing casework through
of
20122 and this is an article uh from
just two months ago I'll just read a
brief uh few sentences the attorney
generals in New Hampshire announced
three men including one man Chester
teacher were arrested for alleged
attempted child sex trafficking at a
Manchester Hotel an investigation led by
Homeland Security
officials
charged three men with attempted sex
trafficking of a
minor Meg chant program director at the
New Hampshire Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual
Violence uh
indicated that
people should be understand child sex
trafficking could happen in any
Community the kidnappings and the cross
borders we're talking about raising
awareness of the fact that this is
happening in New
Hampshire this was just two months
ago and who might that young girl
be I can picture a young girl whose
parents are both working to make ends
meet a young girl who feels unloved
maybe because her parents are always
gone
working then she meets a young man who
promises her the world it's love its
companionship it's caring it's fine for
a while but then he starts bring over
his friends and tells her to be nice to
them and she gets pregnant so what does
he
do he takes her for an
abortion this is the guy we're going
after a sex trafficker we are protecting
that young
girl but we provide Protections in this
bill for people not involved in the
criminal act parents ambulance driver
Good Samaritan a common carrier such as
U Uber
driver and they were all uh explained in
here and we'll go through the amendment
uh briefly
also um and in addition to the criminal
penalties outlined in the first part of
this bill civil penalties are indicated
in page on page
two this legislation will send a message
to predators and sex traffickers that
New Hampshire is not the place for them
combined with other leg legislation that
we will hear uh this coming session we
will send a message please pass this
bill for that young girl and her
parents um looking at the amendment
I'll just highlight what is changed in
the amendment for you from the original
bill um first of all um on line six
we're making sure that this is an adult
who would be guilter guilty of a Class A
misdemeanor in the first
um um
I just noticed an error in the amendment
that I will get um
redrafted uh the word recruits should
have been Stu should have been struck I
just picked this up a few minutes ago
I'm
sorry um so they are guilty of the
misdem misdemeanor um as I said for
concealing or procuring an act that
Constitution an abortion or obtaining an
abortion producing drug for that
unanticipated minor
girl
um for the purpose of this section is
added um at the end of that
uh paragraph um an abortion inducing
drug definition is included
there and that's line 16 and
um down below we we see Roman 4 that
outlines who this does not apply to and
we have anti added in the amendment that
it does not uh apply to the UN
unemancipated minor herself um but also
it applies to you'll see in line in um e
f and g it uh does not apply to um uh
transportation for a medical emergency
such as a miscarriage
does not apply to a Good Samaritan or
situations where the minor hasn't
notification um the section right below
that also at uh this I'm looking at the
top of uh page two does not prohibit a
licensed physician or other person from
calling an ambulance uh for that minor
in a medical
emergency we're again we're going after
the adult who's trafficking or
predatoring um that uh young
lady
um then on
um lines 15 through 17 basically it it
defines um who might bring a civil
action um against the adult involved in
this case and um it uh the final change
in this is a correction to the statute
on line
31 uh but those are really the changes
clarifications made um in this uh
Amendment um and I as I indicated uh
this is about uh making sure that
parents have rights to know what's going
on in the life of their minor
children it's about predators and
traffickers who pray
on young girls um as we've seen um
around the country and as I've indicated
happen right here in New Hampshire and
protecting those young girls from the uh
undue influence of the those predators
and traffickers and I thank you very
much for your
time thank you representative if I may
um does would this I've heard your
emphasis be on these traffickers would
this not also apply to the case of of an
adult male who has an inappropriate
relationship for example with a younger
woman perhaps a student and would
otherwise be guilty of the crime of
statutory rape by going to have this
procedure he'd thus be taking care of
the evidence that would lead to his
conviction that that is true yes yes
thank you further questions
representative um
Sher
um let me divied you've identified this
bill uh as a sex trafficking Bill uh
those words don't appear in this bills
and I'm concerned about the breadth of
the bill um so let me divide it into two
groups
those individuals who are engaged in sex
trafficking and take a minor for an
abortion second group is everybody else
who takes a minor for an abortion for
for example uh 18-year-old boyfriend
takes his 17-year-old girlfriend for an
abortion do you intend this bill to
apply to that second
group um any adult a non-minor an
18-year-old who takes a 17-year-old
girlfriend without to answer the
question please go ahead without without
parental permission yes
yes um follow up
follow up I'm sorry um do you have any
data that establishes that that second
kind of in the people that that event uh
described in the second group that's
actually happening in New Hampshire um
well as you probably know New Hampshire
is one of three states in the nation
that does not capture abortion
statistics do you have any anecdotal
information that that is happening
uh I have no personal I have no personal
antidotal
data um did you not um at the beginning
of your testimony cite some evidence
that you had that it was occurring in
Hampshire with um regard to the sex
trafficking um based on the uh articles
and so forth that I read yes from the
Coalition and all yes so further
followup um followup um Ju Just for for
from a based on the chair's question I
was referring to that second group
um
what what does recruiting
mean um recruiting was an error in um
the amendment that wasn't should have
been struck when drafted um and I will
get that correction
made and last followup uh what does
harboring
mean um
uh harboring um I think would mean um uh
having um um not possession but uh um in
um in
um I'm I'm searching for the word um but
um with the uh young lady maybe having
her an apartment could even be a
kidnapping
answers representative
new thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um in looking at um
the bill and then also who has a right
of action a right of civil action
afterwards so it says that um what would
be required as far as parental consent
would be written and notorized
so if uh are you concerned ConEd and
then it says that of course you know um
people who would have right to civil
action included in that would be the
biological father of the en board Tri so
my my question is are you concerned
about um if there was consent given um
yet they didn't happen to get written
notorized consent that the biological
father that this could be used
maliciously in a situation where there
were issues between the um the
parents of the the biological father is
on line 17 and 18 um uh could not bring
a civil action if the pregnancy is
resulted from his action okay I Y I
understand that okay I'm sorry can I
follow I'm sorry
have let me let me just make it clear
I'm sorry I'm I probably didn't do that
very well um so the requirement for
there to be parental consent yes would
be written and notorized consent yes
consent right correct um and then of the
people who have right to take civil
action the biological father can be
right so if there is a situation in
which the parents did give consent they
just didn't happen to for example get it
notorized there's a there's written
consent but they didn't they couldn't
find a notary right in time um are you
at all concerned that it could be used
this could be used maliciously by a
biological father if there were a
situation where you know they had a
falling out the father you know wasn't
happy about the situation they could
essentially use what is a technicality
created by this law maliciously against
the mother are you concerned about that
I I think that um if it's a matter of
having um uh written uh consent but not
notorized I think the courts would uh
okay thank you I would think that if the
parents U maintain their consent um and
the fact that it wasn't notorized would
only come into play if they were
actually caught during the ACT
afterwards would it not be the case that
the parents would come to court and say
no we did consent to this thus stopping
that case
possibly further
Murray thank you chairman Roy um and
thank you for taking my question sure um
I guess just in response to or curious
about this last part would you object to
the notorized part being removed because
I I do think that places a significant
barrier you know it can be hard for
people to get to notary pay for a notary
Etc it's um it's really your bill at
this point um I just going to make the
uh recruitment uh correction and uh then
it's all
yours so I take it to mean you're
neutral on that
uh yeah probably so I I think that there
are other states that um have also
required notorized um but I have not
looked for all the legislation in other
states so I'm not sure what is required
elsewhere I just wanted to take your
temperature as we discuss this later in
executive what we think would be
amendable um further do you have a
followup okay so you no further
questions thank you for oh once again
represent me that's okay it's
representative
fault who would actually be in charge of
bill um uh the justice system um the uh
police um you know this could be a
criminal case
so so somebody could make a complaint to
a police
officer I would expect that's the case
okay thank you
represent
PR so if the pregnant 17-year-old girl
decides to get in a car and drive
somewhere across state
lines what happens then because I keep
hearing about if somebody's taking her
herself um that would not fall under
this if she goes by herself this would
be accompanied by an adult who takes her
yes see no further questions thank you
thank you very much at this time the
Phillips thank you Mr chair and thank
you members of the committee I'm here
today with you and opposition to HB 191
as amended because for many reasons I
believe it's unenforceable
unconstitutional and potentially invi
politically unviable first if I passed
if passed HB
191 would permit an unprecedented
climate of Big Brother government
surveillance into everyday Granite
Staters lives with real questions about
how law enforcement would be carried out
on a day-to-day basis under this
law are there going to be random teen
pregnancy testings or roadside stops are
there going to be random inspections of
healthcare facilities this surveillance
of which young people are pregnant and
who assists them in obtaining access to
what is currently a legal healthc care
procedure will pit neighbors against
neighbors parents against Healthcare
Providers and family members against
each other second if past HB 191 would
permit an unconstitutional invasion of
privacy into young people's lives here
in New Hampshire as they exercise their
right to travel the right to bodily
autonomy the right to live their lives
free from government intrusion solely
based on their sex and their
reproductive status under current laws
miners can access safe and legal
abortion and have the freedom to travel
to healthcare appointments but miners
need only notify their parents when they
receive an abortion but under HB 191 as
amended minors would now need consent
from their parents prior to receiving an
abortion this law shifts the power of a
young person to decide their own
reproductive fate to power of a parent
who may not have the child's best
interest in mind this is a dangerous
shift of control and the proposed law
does not adequately address the Myriad
cases where this law will invade the
privacy of people here in the granite
state so just imagine a middle schooler
and I should just apologize in advance
for this scenario imagine a middle
schooler being impregnated by a father
who then refuses to consent to a
pregnancy test or an abortion given his
potential criminal exposure then imagine
that father then presses charges under
the law against the trusted person her
mother who drove this young person not
old enough yet to drive to receive their
abortion and protect them from an
unwanted child born out of incest
imagine that father also names the man
who works at the intake desk at the
healthcare provider's office and the
healthcare provider at the medical
facility who helps the mother with her
young child
nothing in this law prevents this
tragedy from unfolding and there are no
exceptions for interf family
disagreements or incest hb11 as amended
is statuto statutory cruelty UNF which
is unfair and discriminates against
women as a class to be clear there is no
equivalent privacy Invasion for males
here in New Hampshire for their
Healthcare and for a state that Prides
itself on living free of government
intrusion there is nothing free about HB
199 191 as
amended third if ped HB 191 as amended
will be politically damaging given the
governor's public statements that she
will veto any further restrictions of
abortion law in this state the potential
exercise of voting for 191 as amended as
OTP will pit supporters of this bill
against our newly elected governor as
you may recall governor aat recently um
campaigned on the promise that abortion
law here in New Hampshire was settled
and it would go un changed while she's
here in the executive office a vote for
191 as amended will reveal a true
internal party disagreement that the
Senate will surely not appreciate having
to debate and determine on the public
record and at last please consider that
the vast majority of granite Staters are
against the restrictions on abortion as
proposed so passage of this bill will
damage the likelihood for future
majorities of the party who passes it
thank you for your time and given the
amount of people who want to speak I'm
going to decline to answer questions up
this time thank you for coming
Hennessy
oops thank you Mr
chair my name is Jason Hennessy I'm the
president for New Hampshire right to
life New Hampshire's largest pro-life
organization and I'm here to
enthusiastically support House Bill 191
I want to start off with a a quote and
uh the name has been changed uh due to
due to the crime but um this is from a
girl named Kayla she said while she was
in forced prostitution I saw 10 to 20
men a day I did what he the pimp said
because he got violent when I sassed him
I took took all kinds of drugs even
though I didn't really like most of them
I had forced unprotected sex and got
pregnant three times and had two
abortions afterward I was back out on
the streets
again when she said this so she started
at
13 and the United States approximately
400,000 minors are involved in
trafficking one study of 66 sex
trafficking victims found that they had
a total of 114
abortions HB 191 would protect these
minors from being taken advantage of all
it does is require that parents are
involved when a minor gets an abortion
who would be scared of that traffickers
and
predators for the rare cases of abusive
parents representative cordell's
Amendment maintains the judicial bypass
available with our parental notification
law this bill plugs a hole in our
current parental notification law
because of abortion pills which can be
ordered over the internet and account
for about 60 to 70% of our abortions
here New Hampshire anybody can get them
you just go can you just go online it's
very
easy New Hampshire has a sex trafficking
problem National human uh according to
the National human trafficking hotline
New Hampshire had 51 identified victims
in 23 64 victims in 2022 and 75 in
21 and as you heard from representative
cordelli uh as a far as as as as recent
as 2022 DCF identified 95 reports of the
trafficking of minors of which 98% were
sex trafficking and of course these are
underestimates there you know many
things go unreported many things go
uncaught I want to I want to also talk
about an example that recently happened
here in New Hampshire that's been
documented uh reading from an nhpr
article Jane Doe's law civil lawsuit
alleges that Gage at the whitec raped
her on a nearly a near weekly basis over
the course of several years o was in
state custody between 2001 and 2005
according to her civil suit she also
claims in her civil suit that she became
pregnant as the as result of the rapes
and that Gage then coerced her into
having an abortion this happened right
here in New Hampshire under State
protection the fact is we have sex
trafficking and we have abuse we need an
adult involved who has the child's
interests at heart whether that's a
parent or a
judge in terms of the constitutionality
representative cordell's recommendation
that of removing the word recruit would
address the issues that have been
brought up in federal court that is the
primary reason that the Idaho bill was
injuncted by district court and the
ninth Circuit of appeals just reinstated
the the rest of that bill and in
December the ninth circuit based in San
Francisco is not known for being a
conservative
Bastion I I'll also mention that the
statute only require requires that the
behavior be within the state of New
Hampshire so in terms of interstate
commerce it only affects behavior that
was here you've heard the bill called
the travel ban or you will in a sense it
is it bans abusers sex traffickers ande
and predators from traveling to get rid
of the evidence of their crime against a
minor girl with an abortion I'm okay
with that there will be many cases where
securing a conviction on the other
aspects of sex trafficking or abuse will
be difficult this bill would protect
girls from their
abusers if you want to address the very
real problem of sex trafficking in New
Hampshire I urge you to vote OTP on hb11
thank
you thank you I just I think I have a
couple of questions because I want to
clarify some things um about what this
bill does or does not do the bill does
not make it illegal for a minor uh to
get an abortion is that correct that's
correct representative if if a minor
female wanted to get an abortion
currently to stated the law is she could
obtain one after parental notification
is that correct that's correct so what
this bill does is it penalizes an adult
who pressures or somehow coerces that
child to get an abortion that he did not
otherwise
want can you clarify that last part
please well in other words if the child
didn't start out wanting an abortion she
wanted to keep the child the term and
this perpetrator came into the scene and
convinced or coerced that child that's
when this law would take effect is that
who this law is targeting in other words
there's no penalty against the child
there's no penalty against the the
abortion provider it's solely the adult
involved in convincing that child to get
the abortion and taking them there thank
you for the question representative my
understanding is it's not the convincing
part it's the assisting part so it's
it's the traveling and um the obtaining
part so simply talking to her I in my
understanding of this bill would not
okay so if a child wanted to get an
abortion say a
16-year-old and she told her parents but
they didn't get any kind of written
notification or something and she took
an Uber and went and got one there's no
issue but if she had an adult driver
that adult would then be subject to this
my understanding of the statute
representative is that it's only if they
do it knowingly so if they're if
somebody just asked for a ride and they
don't know what for I I would imagine
that wouldn't be knowingly thank you
further question our representative um
Sher thank you Mr chair um I I have to
admit I have a I'll try to be brief but
I have a number of questions there's
nothing about pressuring or coercing in
this bill correct that's my
understanding representative um and so
the 18-year-old boyfriend of the
17-year-old minor uh who takes her to
get an abortion because neither of them
want the parents to know and they have
no idea in the world how to do the
judicial bypass process that boy could
one be convicted of a misdemeanor right
that's my understanding and that boy
could be sued by the parents is that
right and that is my understanding um
now right to life is an abortion
organization isn't it uh we're much
bigger than just abortion we we want to
protect women and children okay but uh
you were here when I asked I'm sorry I
keep forgetting to ask for followup yeah
that that and um stick to the questions
about the bill not the organization
please
um you um I'm looking at my notes you
said there uh there's uh data that says
that there were 50 to 75 victims of Seft
sex trafficking in New Hampshire right
uh that's that was what was known by one
report and what number of those 51 to 75
victims uh were
minors um my I let me double
check he said 91% I don't know if I have
down I'm not sure if I have that so a
subset of the 51 to 75 um of that subset
of miners uh how many uh were
transported by someone or harbored by
someone to in order to conceal an
abortion well because we don't keep uh
statistics representative we don't know
okay so we don't know if we're this is a
uh uh a solution in search of a problem
or whether it's actually a a real
problem in New Hampshire uh
representative there are many stories
Nationwide about sex trafficking and
abortion I'd encourage you to look at
that I've I've looked at that I'm asking
about any other questions yeah one more
uh this is going to be a
cross-examination just all right I'll
stop now only to elucidate the committee
no the thing that confuses me about the
testimony that I've heard is that we've
heard over and over and over and over
again about this trafficking and the
trafficking problem and trafficking
adults but trying to get people that are
try doing this hobing and recruiting and
transporting
there's not one mention of tra of of
trafficking in here so maybe we could
make some kind of amendment that says
for people who traffic represent minor
may I interrupt you and ask you look at
bill you could you read that for
okay then I I'll I'll amend the way my
question there is one word in there
about trafficking and now that
trafficking is in there is that only and
and the reason I didn't find it on line
three is I haven't had this amend in
very long oh may I have a followup
oration of question also line five as
well go ahead thank
you okay also line
five
traffing so the law is trafficking of a
but it applies to any adult any adult
whether they're trafficking or not is
that correct any adult who does not have
the pr the parents permission so with so
without the par followup follow up go
ahead so without the parents
permission then any adult male becomes a
trafficker by not getting the parents
permission I'm I'm I'm having a really
difficult time with that is that correct
um I I would look at the lengthy list of
exceptions because there are many many
people who are accepted from that well
also I'll just I'll just I'll just leave
it at that thank you does it apply only
to men a woman could be charged as well
correct yeah okay thank you I'm
representative pro thank you
so I had a
little trouble with clarifying your your
about uh a girl who was forced into
prostitution
and you're worried about her parents not
knowing that she crossed state lines to
get an
abortion does her parents know that
she's in
prostitution uh so so if I understand
your question correctly representative
you're asking um do her parents know
that she was doing in
prostitution right because that's the
example you gave us right a girl forc
prostitution
and you're wor worried about some guy
driving our across state lines to get an
abortion how about stopping the
prostitution so uh to address done if I
may Mr chair if I may address um the
first part of that it the bill does not
talk about state lines at all it says if
the behavior happens within New
Hampshire so there's nothing about state
lines um the second part is that in that
particular story which I'm happy to send
you uh she ran away from home and so the
real goal is to get a parent involved um
get some sort of responsible adult when
when things are going wrong and whether
that's a judge through judicial Bypass
or whether it's a parent um that that's
the
goal I have a a question it occurs to me
why are we focused on on on the the
medical procedure of abortion why is it
not frankly any adult taking a minor to
get a medical procedure without
permission of the parents is problematic
in my be why is it just we focused on
this and why does it say any adult
taking a minor for medical procedure
without their parents permission or
knowledge is a
crime well I would say that thank you
for the question representative I I
would say that abortion is distinct
because from other medical procedures
because in other medical procedures a
person is not a person's life is not
intentionally ended true and and
abortion is actually used I mean I I I
cited that statistic earlier where I
think among 66 trafficking victims uh
there were 114 abortions so particularly
in sex trafficking abortion is used to
cover up the crime I I asked because
there's it's not the only I mean we have
cases of people who are who are being um
having gender reassignment surgeries a
lot of things that young people are
having done now that are medical that
parents in my mind should be at least
notified if they're responsible and safe
parents so I'm curious if if why we're
why we're just eliminating it to one
that's
all um any further questions represent
of
new actually I think I think let me just
so sex sex trafficking is illegal
currently right that's my understanding
um if you were to uh Force someone to
I guess it's it depends on how you
Define coercion force
uh sorry I don't know what I did there
um but my point is that we're focusing
on sex trafficking and I can understand
that that things happen in that
situation that um a lot of things happen
in that situation that are are unsavory
the point is is that that's already
illegal and so this conflating um
conflating these things just seems
off to me because that's not really what
we're doing here and correct me if I'm
wrong but what we're doing here I think
is we are adding to the definition of
trafficking and now saying this also
qualifies as trafficking so it's
it's it seems a little disingenuous to
me to be talking about sex trafficking
and the same and making it seem as if
that's what this bill is doing do you
see it differently thank you for the
question representative I think I would
see would see it differently because
there's a there are a lot of crimes
which are difficult to secure a
conviction for but if we have something
that's con so sex trafficking may may be
one of those crimes so if we have
something concrete that we can say well
this this Behavior was criminal then it
gives us an opportunity as a society to
protect that protect that minor thank
you representative um um
Sher um I'll be uncharacteristically pre
are you aware of HB 231 filed by
representative Perez that prohibits
School District Personnel from
transporting students to medical
procedures without parental consent I'm
not representative um might that be a
better vehicle for uh accomplishing uh a
good bit of what uh um uh chair uh Roy
was
suggesting uh well having not seen the
the bill uh what I would say is that it
sounds like it only covers School
personnel and if there's other people
that are trafficking minors then we want
to make sure that we have we have a
crime for them um might it be a better
vehicle in that it could be amended to
be broader than just School Personnel I
I haven't seen the legislation
it thank you Mr tar thank you for taking
my question um I guess just
a basic um lack of understanding I have
for the need for this bill is it's
already you know parental notification
is already in law and there's already
misdemeanor attached to failure to
notify the parents
so I'm just having a hard time even
imagining a scenario where an individual
is driving a minor to an appointment to
get an
abortion without the parental consent
cuz that that or the parental
notification because that's already
required by law so it's almost like to
me this is this almost opens up like
okay so the minor has the parental
notification to get the abortion but
then now they need to randomly get this
written notorized consent for the drive
to the abort do you know what I mean
like it just kind of like I don't
understand I guess the necessity for it
because we're already have safeguards in
place to prevent abortions happening
without parental notification or
judicial bypass
thank you for the question
representative one of the behaviors that
is covered under the amendment is my
understanding is that it's also
obtaining the abortion pills and giving
them to her so you can go online right
now and Order abortion pills and it asks
you a couple questions which for which
there's no verification and they'll
they'll mail them to you and so I
believe that this bill is needed in the
era of of abortion pills being so
readily available and not NE and not
necessarily just having abortions at a
at a center could not a a minor order
them themselves they could and under
this bill they would be Exempted okay
represent Murray you had to follow
up um I see
you uh well first of all to my
understanding you know anyone who who is
getting abortion pills online is to have
a teleah health appointment with a
medical provider online but I guess with
what you're saying does that mean then
the out of state provider potentially
would then be
liable under this statute for providing
the abortion
pills the my understanding is that the
bill at the top says within the state
okay thank
you in addition to the human trafficking
situation that you've outlined um a
comment on this uh 17-year-old girl has
a 19-year-old sister uh there's a
history of abuse in the family they're
both afraid of what the parents or maybe
one of the parents uh will do if the
younger girl if girl basically goes to
them and tells her that she's pregnant
and she wants to have an abortion the
19-year-old sister uh could get the
chemical drug uh and provide it to her
sister she could drive her sister to an
abortion would the sister basically as
as I read the bill as it as it's
proposed now uh that 19-year-old sister
would be just as guilty of an offense as
the human trafficker is that true so my
understanding of the intent of the bill
is to make sure that there's a
responsible adult involved in this
situation and if the parents really are
that abusive that then having a Judicial
bypass would probably be beneficial
because then you'd have somebody else
looking into it to make sure she's okay
followup follow that may be the intent
of the bill but I don't see that in the
bill
thank you representative if you look at
the list of exceptions the parental
notification in the amendment is there
so if there if there is a parental
notification judicial bypass then the uh
then it's
allowed um i' I've got a final question
and I asked this of the of the
representative as well in in my mind
when I read this I I was also confused
about you know the need why and in my
mind someone guilty of statutory rape
would want to destroy the evidence for
lack of a better term and would indeed
coer or perhaps force a minor to to go
and get an abortion to absolve
themselves of that crime would this
cover that my understanding is that it
would representative also the the right
the the the YDC case that's that's in
the in the papers is example and that's
not even statute that's not statut
that's real rape and it was covered up
with abortion thank you um see no
further questions thank you for your
Eliason hello committee thank you for
letting me speak today um my name is
Hannah Eliason I'm a resident of
hopkington New Hampshire I have two
degrees one from St Lawrence University
in government and religious studies with
an Arabic minor and I have a master's
degree from Harvard University in
authoritarianism Mass violence
rights it would be really nice if this
bill was about sex trafficking wouldn't
that be nice finally in the granite
state we're doing something about it but
that's not what this bill is about and
you all know it you have been asking
these questions that are needed that are
wanted and that are Urgent to our
community this bill is purely about
controlling children's bodies I'm going
to say that again this bill is about
controlling children's bodies girls
bodies it is a slippery
slope Nazi Germany didn't start with
concentration camp it actually started
in
1933 when the Nazis actually destroyed
the institute for sexual science not
anymore there are six women on this
committee out of 15
seats sit with
that you are going to decide an entire
State's rights for women this will not
stop with girls the white supremacist
threat in New Hampshire is as big as as
it's ever been there are 16 active hate
groups in a state of 1.1 million
people we have a state motto that is
Live Free or Die but with this bill it
die again this is a very slippery slope
and this is not one that New Hampshire
wants to travel
down I grew up right behind t Jacob in a
very Interfaith Community I have Jewish
friends Muslim friends Hindu Friends
Christian
friends and this is not what many people
holy you should not legislate people's
bodies if this is what if sex
trafficking is really a big issue which
I know it is we all know it
is make it a sex trafficking
bill I went through conquered High
and I know many many girls who went
pregnant in high
school that's what this bill does is
enforce allow that to become more
frequent not only does it trap girls in
their
hometowns but it makes it harder for
families
overall this decision is between the
child their parents and and their
doctor this is a medical decision this
is not a decision men should be making
to rule over women's
bodies I have family that was in the
Holocaust I'm not Jewish but I my family
was in the Polish
underground and um I've studied language
a lot in my career I want to just pull
up a line from the Fugitive Slave Act of
and it be further enacted that any
person who shall knowingly or willingly
obstruct hinder or prevent such claimant
his agent or attorney or any other
person or persons lawfully assisting him
or or them from arresting such a
fugitive from service or labor either
with or without process as as fores said
or shall rescue or attempt to rescue
such fugitive from service or labor from
the custody of such complainant him and
his attorney or agent and any other
person are per lawfully assisted in as
said
four to escape such um sorry direct or
indirectly to escape from such claimant
his ident agent or attorney or other
persons or persons person or persons
legally authorize and as fores said or
shall
Harbor or conceal such
fugitive as to prevent the discovery and
arrest of such person after notice and
knowledge of the the fact that person
was a fugitive from service or labor as
so forth
said that is what this bill uses
language from to
Harbor that's to hide they didn't want
to say that but that's what that
means you don't want New Hampshire to be
the state that sets this President you
don't not in a state that already has 16
active hate groups and I would be
willing to work with this committee to
make that happen but not this way thank
leak good afternoon chairman Roy and
members of the committee my name is
Rebecca leak and I live in Andover and
I'm testifying in favor of HB
1991 as this bill criminalizes taking a
minor to obtain an abortion without the
consent of the Minor's parents it makes
it illegal for traffickers and other
abusers to bring a minor to obtain an
abortion Studies have shown that
traffickers and other abusers use
abortions to cover up their heinous
crimes and abortion facilities have
frequently failed to report child sexual
sexual abuse thus this law would help
protect vulnerable young women in girls
from abuse and suffering therefore I
urge you to recommend that hb1 91 ought
to pass thank you for considering my
testimony I welcome any
questions San thank you very much for
your
testimony chair calls Jesse
Heath V something you're going to have
to help me
ah good afternoon chairman Terry Roy
Vice chair Jennifer rhods and members of
the committee my name is Jesse Heath
Vincent and as a father and a citizen
I'm here to voice my opposition to this
bill this bill seeks to impose criminal
penalties on anyone who assists a minor
in obtaining an abortion without
parental approval I believe this
approach is punitive unnecessary and
risks significant Harms to the
well-being of vulnerable
minors governance is most effective when
conducted in a bipartisan manner with
compromises that reflect the diverse
needs and the values of our
communities unfortunately this bill does
not reflect this principle instead it is
a divisive measure that clearly aims to
allow parents of minors to restrict
their bodily
autonomy with through the threat of
criminal
penalties RSA 132 already provides a
well balanced bipartisan framework for
addressing these sensitive issues it
ensures that miners can seek abortion
care within a structure that
incorporates parental involvement while
also safeguarding minor rights and
well-being introducing this bill creates
a chilling effect on abortion care
trusted adults and healthc care
providers May fear a criminal
prosecution for supporting a minor
during a deeply personal and often
urgent decision-making process the broad
language would seem to apply to those uh
who would per perform escort care for
those seeking abortions to cross picket
lines
Etc such an outcome would only serve to
isolate miners in need forcing them into
unsafe and unsupported circumstances
rather than advancing this bill I urge
the committee to consider strengthening
RSA 132 section
32-36 by adding narrowly tailored
criminal penalties for individuals who
willfully fail to comply with its
punitive uh compliance with its
Provisions this would reinforce
accountability without introducing
unnecessary duplication and punitive
measures that could harm vulnerable
populations in conclusion I respectfully
request that this committee reject House
Bill 191 um lets us instead work
together across party lines to ensure
that our laws protect minors uphold
bodily autonomy and reflect the values
of fairness and
compassion thank you thank you could you
um could you cite that again you said we
you thought we had to look at 132 yes uh
RSA 132 section specifically sections uh
32 through 36 and could you help do you
have any examples of what that would be
off the top of your head or so that's
the um notification requirements the
current requirements they already law
that
um mandate that the parents are notified
okay and so I think that that's like a
much better Avenue to explore um rather
than as as multiple people have
commented already about the other
individuals who be caught up in this law
as currently written yeah I'm interested
specifically in the in the example I've
cited uh about making sure that someone
who who has impregnated a minor and is
trying to force that minor to cover that
up through an abortion and the
notification might be the angle to
narrow that down
versus yeah I don't have any examples of
that or anything like that I would just
I was just saying that I think that
that's the the method to achieve what
this goal is the the stated goals of
this Bill thank you I appreciate it any
other questions see none thank you thank
you thank you for your
patch good afternoon chairman Roy and
members of the committee and thank you
so much for uh taking uh this time to
listen to me um a lot I am here uh as a
res president of New Hampshire but today
I'm really on acting on behalf of um two
organizations one of the director of all
Girls alloud Incorporated and also a
representative of the New Hampshire
traffic free Coalition I know you've
heard a lot about traffic already but I
want to clarify a couple of points and
then give you a little bit more
statistics to help you understand this
problem a little better first of all I
heard the question if sex trafficking is
already illegal why do we need this
spill
we need this spill because if we could
just go walk around the street and
identify the sex traffickers it would be
very easy to catch them but it's very
difficult to catch a sex trafficker this
bill um enacting of this bill is one of
the ways that we will raise red flags to
help us identify sex traffickers and and
um and then start those criminal
proceedings also I've heard so many
people talk about how this bill is an
measure that will allow abort um their
crimes to be covered up but in the case
of trafficking this is a this bill would
help to stop the continued exploitation
of girls who are stuck in sex
trafficking a recent study that was
published in 2023 in the journal issues
in law and
Medicine did um a complete reproductive
study on survivors of sex trafficking
65% of those
survivors had at least one abortion so
you've heard a lot of numbers about how
many kids are being trafficked I'm here
to tell you 65% of those have had at
least one abortion the majority of them
have had multiple abortions One Survivor
said at the age of 15 they put me in a
group home where I met a pimp who
eventually forced me into prostitution
he was vicious and kept me under his
control by abusing me physically and
mentally I was homeless I felt like I
didn't have anywhere to go anywhere to
get clothes or food or shelter during
the time I was trafficked I had three
abortions here's three other statements
from other survivors as part of this
study I got pregnant 12 times I had
three abortions three children and many
miscarriages another one says I was
pregnant three times during the time I
was trafficked and all of them were by
different
buyers a third person said I felt that
given the circumstances we were living
in one C hotel after another and I
didn't see any end to it I couldn't
bring a baby into the world so I had an
abortion the report goes on to state
that the responses given by the
survivors show a clear lack of choice
with regard to abortion and many
traffickers don't have any say
whatsoever Darlene Pollock who was
supposed to be here with me today is a
survivor of juvenile sex trafficking in
New Hampshire and a valued colleague in
our work against trafficking and
exploitation when she got pregnant her
trafficker said I will kill you if you
don't have an
abortion survivors who endure this type
of ongoing trauma face not only
significant mental challenges but
potentially irreversible physical issues
One Survivor stated I had so many
problems that I believe are connected to
when I was trafficked I had vaginal
infections UTI pelvic inflammatory
disease cysts and scar tissue from
abortions when I got out and married I
couldn't get pregnant now I have uterine
cancer New Hampshire girls who are stuck
in this cycle need our help to get out
and imposing the penalties provided by
this bill is one way to intercept
trafficking situations save victims and
provide them with the support that they
really need so we arege you to follow
the examples of Idaho and Tennessee on
abortion trafficking and pass this
important
legislation thank
you um just a quick question if you
don't mind yeah does this does this
language mirror those two states
identically or is it depart
significantly um I haven't had a chance
to to compare word by word um I think
it's close except that in our language
it's instate transportation to an
abortion okay right and I I can't speak
to all of the issues related to this
bill but definitely from a trafficking
perspective our primary concern is as I
stated this would help to stop ongoing
exploitation um because these girls are
it it it just continues over and over
and over again and um and also just uh
trying to expose those traffickers and
get them off the street this is a great
way to find them and um get them on that
path to Justice we would also urge the
state to consider good measures um for
so some of these girls know that they
have a choice um they could give the
baby up for adoption there's there's
other choices um and and provide some of
the support services that are really
needed if somebody makes that choice
thank
you who did oh yeah go ahead represent
Murray thank you m thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
yeah um I guess I'm still stuck on you
know so you said that this could help
identify those trackers or traffickers
better than we already can um in what
way do you think that would happen
because again we come back to you
already have to do parental notification
for an abortion so if if this is the
problem we're trying to
solve how is the trafficker not being
stopped or identified at that point when
the parent is being notified of the
abortion and like in what way does this
change that scenario at all I'm just not
sure how this will somehow bring to
light trafficking that has not been
already identified in other manners yes
thank you for the question and I I made
a note to myself to explore more on the
par parental notification issue um but I
I believe that uh and many of us have
all seen like the sitcoms and and these
medical shows where there's the person
in the hospital with the trafficking
victim um so I'm not sure how the uh how
people get around that today um but
certainly that would have to be I think
built into the implementation of this
bill um to ensure that that parental
notification is present and then when
it's not
additional you know questions
conversation or whatever a flag goes up
to say this is a person who may be
trafficking this and it's not only just
the trafficker you know it's not these
guys are not going to come in and you're
going to see these crazy looking guys a
lot of times they use a bottom girl to
do actually some of these
transportations and things like that and
manage their victim so it's might look
like a sister it might look like an aunt
um those kinds of things and it may be
that parental notification is easily
forged I I don't know what how that that
happen so thank you um well I guess that
kind of illustrates though what I'm
saying that I don't really see how it
makes identifying the trafficker easier
because I I don't necessarily think you
know the traffickers following the girl
into the appointment Etc um for the
parental notification basically it's
written consent that has to be given or
a written notification to the parents 48
hours before the appointment so there's
not really like a way to forge like that
just written consent and then there's a
misdemeanor charge for the provider if
they don't um give that
notification
um I guess there's not too much of a
question there but yeah I just I'm still
stuck on this like I don't really see
how it increases the chance of
identifying these traffickers because
you know we're not following them in the
car like we're not going out to the car
to bring the girl into the appointment
you know what I mean I'm just like I I
just don't see how this like yeah and
and and it's prob and thank you for the
question it's probably very similar to
some of the ways that it's identified
now if a care provider suspects that
there's an issue then a red flag would
go up you know so a lot of it really
would be in the implementation of the
bill for
Muse yes thank you for taking my
question earlier today we heard a
testimony on a bill that actually dealt
directly with human trafficking and one
of the things that we learned about was
that uh police officers ERS Homeland
Security and uh uh a bunch of different
advocacy organizations in New Hampshire
have been participating in something
called the human trafficking taas task
force is that something that your
organization participates in um thank
you for the question uh we are the New
Hampshire traffic free Coalition is is
absolutely aware of that some of our one
of our leaders used to be on the task
force in fact um
currently I actually went out to their
website in preparation for this and and
didn't find a lot of current information
out there um so I think we uh would love
to see um more engagement on that front
I I believe at one point they were
separate organization and then they
merged with domestic violence um and so
some of the trafficking issues kind of
got a little bit uh had to buy for
attention if you will um but we are
willing to work with anybody we are also
absolutely happy to help in any way um
to
uh advise inform um research investigate
um my other organization all girls
alloud has been fighting trafficking
mainly at the national level and so um
we're also following all federal laws
online exploitation and all of that so
we would be happy to help in any
way thank you thank you uh
representative
Sher thank you I you know I too I'm very
concerned about the issue of sex
trafficking I think it's a really
difficult issue it's hard it's hard to
discover it and and it's hard to punish
it um I think this bill is much broader
than that as as we've heard so let me
ask you this question do you have a copy
of the bill with you uh I don't have the
copy of the bill I'm so
sorry okay the line seven reads
intentionally recruit or intentionally
Harbors or transfer transports a
pregnant un un unemancipated minor
within this state for the purpose of
then it goes on if that language were to
change to intentionally coerces or
forces a pregnant unemancipated minor
within the state for the purpose of
would you uh would that deal more
directly with the sex trafficking
issue um thank you for the question I I
believe it would and we would um we we
would be happy to see that from a
trafficking perspective thank you
represent any further questions seeing
none thank you for your test okay thank
you so much for your
chairman Roy and members of the
committee my name is Dr Cynthia rasmason
and I am a New Hampshire resident I'm a
retired obstetrician gynecologist having
practiced for 32 years and I'm here
today to express my concern about House
Bill
191 this bill provides criminal and
civil penalties sorry penalties for
providing certain assistance to obtain
an abortion for a pregnant unemancipated
minor without parental consent I want to
share some personal experience with you
in the last week I've had two
conversations with an education
professional who works in a high school
in a small town in Southern New
Hampshire and she told me that uh since
the start of school four months ago um
she's had four young girls disclosed
that they were uh they had unintended
and want unwanted pregnancies these
girls were ages 17 16 15 and 13
13 um in my uh sources
experience um the the number of girls
getting pregnant seems to be increasing
in her school despite National Trends
and that the ages at which these young
girls conceive is actually getting
younger now this is the observation of
one education professional multiply this
experience by every school nurse every
guidance counselor every teacher every
uh coach every athletic trainer in every
High School in the state and you begin
to understand the scope of of the
problem fortunately the issue of teen
pregnancy has been on the medical radar
for some time and we do have good data
regarding many aspects of this problem
in a perfect world all teens would
disclose their condition of their
parents and involve them in the
decision- making and I totally agree
that that is the best case scenario and
the optimal place for this to happen and
in fact two-thirds of pregnant teens do
disclose to their parents it is that
other third for whom this legislation
presents a problem data suggests that
they may have really good reasons for
not telling their parents including
concern about being forced to continue
the pregnancy get the very real
possibility of getting kicked out of the
house and in rare cases being subjected
to violence they may already be um
victims of incest or abuse so who are
these pregnant teens especially the most
the the third that that feel that they
cannot disclose well pregnant teenagers
are 7% of teenage girls in the United
States they're most the they're most
likely from backgrounds of low income
low education and neighborhood
disadvantage their pregnancies are
diagnosed later and they enter prenatal
care later these girls are plagued by
poor social support poor emotional
well-being and have high levels of
depression they have higher use of
tobacco alcohol and recreational drugs
and they do not change those habits
during pregnancy their home environments
are often unstable or unsafe and some of
them are
unhoused whether it is intended or not
the effect of this bill will be to make
access to abortion care more difficult
for the most vulnerable pregnant teens
by Criminal izing the effort of those
who would help them it's well documented
that of all teens who choose to keep and
parent their babies only 40% of them
will finish high school and of those
less than 2% will go on to finish
college pregnancies and adolescents are
highrisk and complex to treat um they
have a higher incidence of ectopic
pregnancy pre-term birth low birth
weight complications from high blood
pressure poor nutrition and anemia
depression substance use and genital
infections are more
common unfortunately coercion and
intimate partner violence is a major
problem for this population and
Adolescent mothers have a very high rate
of repeat pregnancy a quarter of them
will be pregnant again within a year and
a third of them will be pregnant again
within two years and what happens to the
children that these that these teenage
mothers bear um they because teenage
mothers who are coerced into having
children children have much more
difficulty bonding with their children
that the the the children have higher
rates of abuse and neglect are more
likely to become teen mothers themselves
and are more likely to be incarcerated
when you prevent women from accessing
abortion you subject them to the very
serious risk of a pregnancy against
their will you threaten their health and
in few cases cause their deaths if a
young pregnant cannot talk to their
parents for whatever reason and any
other trusted adult in their sphere
faces criminal prosecution for helping
them please remember that suicide is the
second most common cause of death in
children under the age of 18 now why
don't they just uh emancipate themselves
in order to qualify as an emancipated
minor in New Hampshire an adolescent
must be married or in the military or
living independently and managing their
own finances or they must petition the
court for limit emancipation if they're
16 or 17 these requirements are Out Of
Reach for most of the girls who would be
affected by this legislation including
that
13-year-old further this bill may very
well be unconstitutional a law which
brings no health benefits to patients
but makes abortion harder or impossible
to access violates the undue burden
standard that the Supreme Court has used
to evaluate abortion restrictions since
Planned Parenthood vcy in addition an
abortion restriction whose stated
purpose is to protect Women's Health
must be based on demonstrated benefits
and not just on the stated intent of the
lawmaker this bill will not accomp is
not accompanied by valid data or
empirical studies that indicate that it
would actually improve Women's Health if
your intent is to reduce the incidents
of abortion in New Hampshire it would be
a much more productive use of your
legislative powers to address the root
causes of teen pregnancy provide sex
education in schools increase access to
birth control and increase affordable
housing and the social safety net which
these girls desperately need for
successful adolescent parenting those
objections are not addressed in in h
Bill 95 uh 191 and I would urge this
committee strongly not to support it
thank you for your time and
consideration of my testimony I would
sorry my foot fell asleep um thank you
uh kathen Stratton speaking on behalf of
the medical society today of New
Hampshire um I want to thank you all for
for listening and for hearing all the
testimony um I'm speaking in opposition
to this bill um we've heard some
testimony from uh Dr m in earlier and I
and I won't I'm going to cut about half
of my testimony out um but I did want to
uh reiterate some a few things that I've
heard and that I that I've heard from
Physicians um you know that that
relationship between the patient and
Physicians is is very very important and
um that they be seen as a trusted
resource and a safe resource um medical
societ is highly concerned about
trafficking um in New Hampshire and um
of women and
minors and we don't feel that this Bill
gets at the heart of that issue
um there is a concern that the bill will
impact um access to appropriate medal
medical care for Miners and remove
Physicians from a possible um resource
and um support system for miners that
are being trafficked um as we've heard
before um the likelihood of minors
seeking um procedures outside of the
medical system will probably increase if
it's perceived to be an unsafe um
resource for if the medical um abortions
are perceived to be an unsafe
resource um which will result in
decreased access to appropriate medical
care for these young women further
victimizing them and it will not change
the the the experience of being
trafficked it will not change the
experience of being pregnant but it
could change the outcome of their
medical care so we'd like to ask you to
not support this bill um and I I will
tight quarters back there good afternoon
committee thank you for taking the time
to hear my testimony uh for the record
my name is Courtney Reid and I serve as
policy Advocate on behalf of the ACLU
New Hampshire and I'm here to testify an
opposition to House Bill
191 uh we've heard a lot of concerns uh
with different provisions of the bill
but I'm here to speak to the
Constitutional threats that it would
impose on granite Staters um in a few
different ways uh I speak to these in
more detail in my testimony so I'll just
outline them at a high level for now um
the first concern we have is with how
the bill might affect freedom of speech
and expression
for grite Staters uh mostly because it
is unclear what activities would be
prohibited under the bills uh harboring
and
transport uh language so for example uh
with harboring could sitting in uh a
room with a counselor exploring one's
options constitute harboring um would
encouragement or emotional support or
outof state referrals fundraising
coordinating Transportation um would any
of these activities which are protected
act activities that constitute free
speech and freedom of expression uh
would they be
prohibited under this bill and to
elaborate on that the reason why the
courts have deemed these activities is
protected activities is because they are
serving to communicate a core belief of
supporting abortion access and the right
to
abortion um with that lack of clarity I
think that bridges into the second
concern that we have with the bill which
is a due process or one's ability to be
treated fairly and equally under the law
uh 14th Amendment concern and that's
just because the bill is vague and that
it would require adults to make
individual determinations about whether
or not they are harboring or
transporting so it would leave a
supportive adults in a position of
individually attempting to determine
just how much support they could provide
to a young person without those actions
being interpreted as a criminal offense
and ultimately this would as we heard in
the past testimony really discourage
vulnerable young people from seeking
support and exploring their
options lastly um I think these things
really raise a lot of questions as to
what this bill would look like on the
ground and it certainly raises questions
about the fundamental right to
travel uh the bill has a provision
regarding obtaining or procuring
abortions with language States
regardless of the location so of course
abortion is legal and accessible in New
Hampshire um it's also legal and
accessible in other states and so um
what this bill is doing in effect would
be prohibiting Interstate travel um it
would it would mean that it would be
difficult for individuals to go to other
states where they would be legally
accessing care and then being at risk of
criminal offenses in New
Hampshire and and with that I think that
really raises questions as to what
enforcement would look like would there
be someone watching the border on
93 um lastly we have another concern
with the need to go to a notorized um or
a public notary to receive parental
consent uh I think there's just a lot of
concerns about uh having public health
information uh in the hands of someone
else um who to my understanding would
not be a hippo protected official um
with those things we have other concerns
and I'm happy to take questions on them
but uh ultimately Granite Staters value
access to abortion they value their
privacy and this bill uh fundamentally
would bolster government interference
into the private life of granite Staters
um and families and so for those reasons
we would ask the committee to itl this
bill um with that happy to take
questions thank you could you point me
to the section that talks about
interstate I I can't find that sure uh
just give me one moment um I'm looking
at the amendment to HB
191 uh and in line 12 uh procuring it
closes with regardless of where the
abortion is to be procured and in line
15 regardless of where the inducing drug
is
obtained and thank you for your question
thank
you forther questions representative
n
um maybe not a question I it's
interesting I was notary and I I never
saw anything like this and can't imagine
uh somebody coming in and and uh being
responsible for someone else's medical
anyway thank you for bringing that up
I'm sorry that wasn't a question I
thought it was I swear I thought it was
going to
be anyone with an actual question
represent
circumstance
uh offering the document
thank you for your question
representative I believe that would be
work thank you for your question
representative yes uh I'm aware of that
question and I think it speaks to um not
only us constitutional concerns that
this bill raises but also State
constitutional
concerns thank you thank
you see no further questions thank you
thank
Montgomery good afternoon members of the
committee excuse me I will be very brief
I know this hearing has gone quite over
U my name is Kayla Montgomery I'm the
vice president of public affairs for
planed Parenthood New Hampshire action
fund and PPN um it's nice to be back in
this committee um I just really wanted
to briefly talk about the parental
notification law in New Hampshire
because that has come up a couple times
um so you know I think it's just really
important that we remember that the vast
majority of teens um already involve
their parents in these decisions around
pregnancy um and they would do so
regardless of a state mandate but here
in New Hampshire we do have a state
mandate um parental notification has
been uh on the books for well over a
decade here in this state and of course
Planned Parent of Northern New England
uh is a nonprofit healthcare providers
that follows all state and federal laws
uh if we didn't we would have to close
our doors and we couldn't serve patients
um so we certainly at Planned Parenthood
and all abortion providers comply with
the law especially on Parental
notification um and it's very explicit
pintal notification is very explicit in
the law where it's laid out it's RSA 132
sections 32 through 36 so it gives
really clear guidelines of how to comply
with the law so like I said often most
often a parent will come in um but if
you look at the RSA you can see some
more details about what else can be done
around written notice to the home
address uh delivered personally uh at
least 48 hours in advance you can look
through all those yourself if you'd like
um and of course there's a couple of
small um exceptions to this one being a
medical emergency if there's no time um
insufficient time to provide the notice
and then the other case um and
fortunately it's very rare but it does
happen where um a young person feels
like they can't notify their parent and
so judicial bypass is an option um it
doesn't happen very often if you wanted
to know more about those numbers of how
often that happens um New Hampshire
Superior Court um I believe could
provide those numbers um but we're not
talking about a lot of cases there we're
talking um you know really a handful a
year um and then secondly um the issue
of coercion has come up a couple times
and I just want to make really clear
that that is something that Planned
Parenthood and New Hampshire abortion
providers really um take care of and
scan for and make sure that that's not
happening um and this is really built
into all of our intake procedures making
sure that no coercion is happening
asking the patient lots of questions
asking them during the intake procedure
in alone asking multiple times asking um
even during the procedure uh and if
anything comes up we could certainly
would uh flag that would stop the
procedure would make sure that people
are comfortable it is individualized
care and making sure that know one as
being coerced into having an abortion is
of utmost priority so I just wanted to
um just mention those couple of things
questions see no questions thank you
very much is there anyone else wish to
testify who has not turned in the pink
card or testified already seeing none I
hereby close the public hearing on House
Bill
57 excuse me that's incorrect House Bill
191 um and we open the house bill
57 and I invite the prime sponsor
57 no one I just have
one okay good I want to hurry up I get
ambitious I was
going see
she
organization ala okay thank you Mr chair
uh my name is representative David Muse
uh I'm from Rockingham uh District 37
representing the city of Portsmouth and
the towns of Newington and Newcastle
one of the great pleasures of being a
legislator on this committee are the
relationships we develop with the people
who come before us over the summer I
contacted Helen Hanks the commissioner
of the Department of Corrections and I
asked her if there was any legislation
on her mind that would be helpful for me
to file the bill before us today is the
result of that
conversation what HB 57 would do would
be to allow a person under the control
of the department who's been approved
for release under administrative home
confinement to participate in
postsecondary educational opportunities
in the community where they've been
accepted for enrollment under the
current law residents in our state
prison system who are approved for
administrative home confinement are
authorized to take part in employment
opportunities and uncompensated public
service outside their home as long as
they return to their home by a specific
time this bill would simply add
attending college courses as part of
their confinement and that's it what the
bill does not do is change
eligibility anything about the process
or any other aspect of the law it also
doesn't change the Department's policies
for administrative home confinement and
to be very clear this is not a program
that just any Resident in our state
prison system uh is eligible for uh any
Resident who's had disruptive or violent
behavioral issues or who's been
convicted of committing uh uh Escape uh
aggravated DOI or any one of a long list
of violent crimes is not eligible for
administrative home
confinement just like those working a
job or on an
apprenticeship people attending college
courses under administrative home
confinement will be supervised and
monitored by the divisions or by the
Department's division of field services
who check their location through
electronic monitoring and home visits
the cost to the state is negligible
which which is why we we don't have a
fiscal note with this one uh and also a
question that I know that comes up
frequently when we talk about secondary
postsecondary education for for inmates
is who's paying for it uh the answer
here is it's the inmates the families it
could be scholarships it's not the state
of New
Hampshire but while the cost is
negligible um the results are tangible
and real uh separate studies from both
the ran corporation uh and the Vera
Institute have found that incarcerated
people who participate in college
programs are 43 to 48% less likely to be
reincarceration than those who don't and
employment rates for formally
incarcerated students also increase by
an average of 10% after participating in
postsecondary educational opportunities
so in essence what it does is it it
provides people with a better
opportunity not to reoffend not to come
back um I would ask that you hold your
questions um I am not an expert on
administrative home confinement we have
people here who are who can answer any
questions you have about the process I
understand that Nick Duffy from the
Department's division of rehabilitative
services uh is actually going to testify
and he can answer any specific questions
you have around how administrative home
confinement Works uh or why the
department is specifically asking for
this legislation at this time
thank you um uh my name is Nick Duppy I
the director of rehabilitative services
for the New Hampshire Department of
Corrections uh and thank you to
representative Muse for bringing this um
legislation forward uh we think it's
really important for education and
providing opportunities for people to
engage in education um as representative
Muse stated um the statistics are clear
on uh the benefits and uh reduction in
um reincarceration that occurs um when
when those individuals uh participate in
um in higher education opportunities
specifically uh our uh again this
legislation really just adds in that
they for participation in higher
education opportunities um are are we do
a thorough review process for people who
are um requesting to go um on
administrative home confinement that
includes reviewing housing reviewing um
how they're going to finally support
themselves uh treatment opportunities um
we we review the their entire uh release
plan um and make sure that we we believe
that release plan is going to set them
up for Success um upon release and and
education is a part of those um
opportuni so we want them to be engaged
in treatment we want them to be engaged
um in uh really Community Services
that's going to help um them be
successful upon release uh their
behavior avior is a huge factor in us
our approval if they're not behaving
themselves if they haven't completed
programming if they haven't done the
things they've needed uh to show that
they're ready for release um their
application would be
denied um I'd be willing to take any
time representative
lels yes thank thank you for uh taking
my question
I'm
um concerned about the definition of
postsecondary
Education would that include perhaps uh
education in the trades or a uh um an
internship where uh a prisoner would go
out on various sites and work with a
journeyman uh would that be includ
included in postsecondary education uh
yes it would be thank you for the
question but yes it would be um I uh uh
any any really would be any accredited
college or university that um could
provide that education um that would be
a part of that um that
request
followup your definition of college or
university uh many of the trades go
through trade schools and and and and so
forth so you know college or
university um is a little bit different
from my idea of becoming a plumber or a
carpenter or or a farmer or something
like
that so there's an accreditation process
for uh educational institutions um and
so they would have to fall under um the
accreditation procedures for uh I guess
postsecondary education uh services so
typically postsecondary education would
be that post High School level so if
we're talking about a community college
system would would qualify so we would
have to look at that but if you feel
that you think we need more detail and
that another
follow-ups my my only concern is that
based upon the way this is written it
might give someone the idea that we're
separating trade schools from
colleges and in
today's
um economic
environment uh becoming a plumber is
better than becoming uh a history
teacher for
instance yeah we understand that I think
the intent is is that going into the
trades um would be a part of uh the
education with this so um uh that's
something that we could absolutely look
into and and provide some uh more clear
guidance on on that language and but
that's absolutely it's the intent wasn't
to separate those it was uh that they
could go into a a trade um but anything
sort of uh um I guess I'm looking at it
almost as post high school education um
uh so vocational training um that they
could they could
attend thank
you
share thank you madam Pier um and thank
you for your testimony um I know houses
of
Corrections are authorized to uh Grant
Work Release often at the recommendation
of a a sentencing judge uh does the
state prison are they included within
that legislation that authorizes
uh work release yeah so we we have um
Work Release we run three transitional
housing units and a transitional work
center um where people can um once
authorized by the courts to be on work
release they can go into the community
um and uh participate in uh work yes uh
and would to follow up on uh
representative lel's question would an
internship uh with uh an electrician
master electrician or or D an
electrician or a plumber would uh would
that qualify for work
release um so yes um that would uh
generally speaking um they're getting
paid um to do that so they're still
getting a a paycheck like everyone else
um even though they're doing the
apprenticeship they get paid as well for
that what if they weren't get pting paid
for the I'm sorry follow-up
question what if they weren't getting
paid it was just a a a a free
internship
um would that matter I don't believe so
they can still be a part of our programs
um with work release the thing with work
release Tech U typically is that they're
still working because they need to be
able to support themselves in some way
so they might be working part-time in
those cases so they are still working um
they're just getting an opportunity to
um to uh do additional education through
the apprenti ship but we don't I haven't
seen any that aren't getting paid
through that their internship but um yes
that would that would cover it thank you
thank you represent roads thank you Mr
chairman um this question might be
specifically for Miss Graham and it was
kind of a followup on representative L
cell's question so in in the example of
let's say the person is is being
released on a like a work release
and generally that would be you know
you're going from a specifically to be
in a scenario like let's say maybe it
would be like a construction site right
if if the
person is now maybe going with like a
different group of people could you
maybe explain how is that something that
you would basically be able to supervise
or manage that or be able to make the
decision on who would be able to qualify
for as an example as a trade not
necessarily going to a specific
education
building so thank you for that question
representative I I want to be careful
that we're not conflating um
administrative home confinement and work
release because they're two separate
sections um administrative home
confinement as far as monitoring is
concerned they would have electronic
monitoring um they it's different from
work release it's just a separate
separate set of Statute um so F you know
um director Duffy talked a little bit
about our work release programs and what
people are authorized to do current ly
under current law with administrative
home confinement um employment in
general is a criteria that the
commissioner can use to release somebody
on administrative home confinement um we
this is why we were looking to add um
education to that but are you asking
about like accredit how would we look at
accreditation of the program or how
would we monitor them when they're
out yeah the latter so you know like I
have a I have a friend that owns a
suspended ceing company right so he he
is happy to train anybody that wants to
do that cuz he doesn't want to do it
anymore right so in this situation like
if he was contacted and he was like yep
I'm happy to do that how how would that
because he's not go you're not going to
a specific building you're going to job
sites multiple job sites throughout the
day so how would you be able to monitor
that or make the decision who was able
to qualify for that thank you for that
um so we use electronic monitoring for
individuals who are on administrative
home confinement for lack of a better
term ankle bracelet um we can monitor
their location they're under the
supervision of our Field Services
Division so they would have a probation
parole officer who would be following
their case doing home visits um they
would be uh also office visits so they
are under supervision with an officer
directly but they also have that
electronic piece so that we can monitor
where they are you're
welcome see no further questions thank
you give you a testimony is there anyone
else wishing to testify on this bill who
has not being none I here by Clos public
hello I'm Claudia stelle from aworth and
I'm an adjunct in the community college
system I teach at River Valley um I a
remedial math class there and I would
just I'm speaking in favor of this bill
I've had students from 17 to 66 and one
person that I'm thinking of particularly
when I heard about this bill was a young
man who had been um in the in the
judicial system as a youngster so he was
coming to my class with about a sixth
grade education in math um and the math
class I teach is a really good
opportunity to build confidence as well
as skills and I just think that this is
a great opportunity to help people who
have um a lot of students who are in the
community college system are working out
of their comfort zones they are trying
to build skill levels um that that they
didn't have overcome bad experiences
that they had when they were for this
young man in junior high but for most
students in high school um and trying to
get to a place where they can get um a
certificate or an associates degree um
some of them then go on to get uh
bachelor's and Masters as well but um
they are they're starting the process of
trying to um build up their skill level
over overcome learning disabilities that
they may have maybe mental illness
issues or or physical health issues so
that they can actually you know better
themselves when we talk about pulling
people pulling themselves up by by their
bootstraps col community college
students are doing that and if this bill
allows us to expand the number of of
people who can take part in that program
and then can get to a place where they
are becoming productive members of
society and not um falling back into Old
Habits or old whatever and and end up
being in prison again I think it's a
great idea thank you thank you for your
testimony see no
questions s thank you for taking my
question and I truly appreciate the work
that you do um I'm just wondering in
your case where do you deliver your
classes are they inside the walls are
they at your junior college or where
where is it that you deliver your
classes so I teach at River Valley
Community College at usually at the Keen
Center um River Valley has a campus in
Claremont but they have two Satellite
campuses as well so I'm usually at the
Keem campus and we are now on the Keen
State College campus so I'm either
teaching in the River Valley building
which is on the edge of Campus or I'm
teaching in one of the Comm one of the
classrooms um on the Keen State campus
and sometimes um the classes are hybrid
sometimes they're in person okay
followup so if if you were able to
participate as this
bill uh
envisions how would the
prisoners who are getting ready to be uh
paroled or whatever getting out of
prison how would they participate in
your classes would they come to you for
those
classes um sir I I'm I'm not sure
because the I I I'm not familiar with
what the um what the prison system is
okay but um they could participate
remotely okay in other words they could
stay wherever they are already located
and then um join the class by Zoom or
they could come in person I think that
there's something to be said for uh
inperson teaching particularly at this
level at the lower levels where people
um they're they're rebuilding confidence
as much as skills and and it that
requires a a personal relationship so
being in the same room together helps
see no further questions thank you is
there anyone else wishing to testify
seeing none I hereby close the public
hearing and I open the public hearing on
House Bill 511 and invite the prime
sponsor to come forward and introduce
great thank you chairman Roy and members
of the House criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee thank you for the
opportunity for me to introduce House
Bill 511 legislation designed to
strengthen Public Safety and uphold the
rule of law in New Hampshire over the
years New Hampshire has prided itself on
being a state that values safety
community and respect for the laws of
our land HB 511 reflects those values by
addressing a critical Gap in our legal
framework the need to ensure cooperation
between local and state entities and
federal law enforcement in matters of
immigration this bill makes it clear
that New Hampshire will not support
policies or practices that obstruct the
enforcement of federal immigration laws
let me get let me Begin by explaining
why this bill is necessary across the
country so-called Sanctuary policies
have created challenges for law
enforcement undermining their ability to
work collaboratively with federal
agencies the these policies often result
in dangerous individuals avoiding
deportation returning to communities and
committing further crimes while New
Hampshire has largely avoided the issue
we've seen troubling examples in other
states that aren't too far away that
highlight the risks HB 511 takes a
proactive approach to ensure this does
not become a problem here this bill does
three things primarily it prohibits
state and local government entities from
adopting Sanctuary policies this ensures
a consistent approach to law enforcement
across the state a patchwork of
conflicting policies creates confusion
inefficiency and risks it mandates
cooperation with Federal immigration
authorities law enforcement agencies
will be required to honor immigration
detainers allow Federal authorities
access to individuals in custody and
share relevant information about
immigration status it creates a
mechanism for enforcement if any state
or local entity violates the provisions
of this act the Attorney General is
empowered to intervene ensuring
accountability and adherence to the law
now I do want to be clear about what
this bill does not do it does not ask
local law enforcement to take on the
role of immigration officers or detract
from their primary responsibility of
ensuring Public Safety in their
communities rather it ensures that our
state and local agencies do not obstruct
Federal immigration enforcement critics
May argue against this Common Sense bill
but I would ask who benefits when our
laws are not not enforced certainly not
the law-abiding citizens of New
Hampshire certainly not the victims of
crime that would have been prevented if
Federal authorities were able to act
this bill is about protecting our
communities and supporting our law
enforcement agencies in their mission to
uphold the law I'd also like to point
out that HB 511 is part of a broader
commitment to maintaining the Safety and
Security of our state we cannot ignore
the interconnected nature of law
enforcement in today's world
whether we're addressing drug
trafficking human trafficking violent
crime or any other issue we rely on a
strong participation between local state
and federal agencies to keep New
Hampshire safe this bill sends a clear
message New Hampshire stands for the
rule of law and we will not allow
policies that compromise the safety of
our communities or undermine the ability
of law enforcement to do their jobs in
closing HB 511 is not about politics
it's about Public Safety
it's about ensuring that our law
enforcement agencies have the tools
Clarity and support they need to protect
New Hampshire families I urge you to
consider the benefits of this
legislation that they will bring to our
communities and vote to recommend HB 511
as ought to pass thank you and I'm very
happy to take any questions the
committee may
have thank you representative questions
representative
Sher thank you Mr
chair
so let's assume a person uh is arrested
by a political Police Department uh for
a crime then you know misdemeanor or
felony local police department becomes
aware that there is a detainer out on
that person could you name the police
departments that you're aware of in New
Hampshire that do not call uh ice I I
know there have been talks thank you for
the question representative I know there
have been talks in the past uh some
communities out in Chester County have
adopted sanctuary policies uh and there
is a sanctuary policy agreement with the
Hillsboro County
Corrections follow up um I want
to talk I want to not use not ask
questions about Sanctuary policies
because that that's a big umbrella of
possible policies what I'm interested in
is do you know of any jurisdictions who
when a person has been arrested for a
crime and they become aware that there's
a a federal immigration container out
that that either that police department
or that household correction has not
called ice I in hearing your question I
think it's an impossible one to answer
because if that police department does
not cooperate with ice we would not know
about the lack of cooperation if they
were to pick somebody up that has an
immigration detainer
followup um so I want to make a
distinction between an individual who
has a f Federal detainer immigration
detainer out but who hasn't committed a
crime right well if they're in the
country illegally they've committed a
crime no let me let me finish my
question understanding that it is not a
federal crime to be undocumented in the
United States it's a federal crime to
cross the border when you're
undocumented it's not a federal crime to
be to be president in the United States
and be undocumented given that uh when
there is a detainer uh uh immigration
detainer on somebody who has not
been uh is not charged with a State
Crime do you think does this bill apply
to that person or does it only apply to
somebody who's in custody of the uh of a
local facility be or the police as I
said in my testimony this does not
direct local New Hampshire law
enforcement at the local level or the
state level to become immigration
enforcers uh it simply directs them to
cooperate with ice in their activities
um so it wouldn't be you know local
police officers wouldn't be going out
into communities to find uh those that
are here illegally uh those illegal
aliens that are here it will just they
will be working with ice when they do
arrest somebody for other crimes as you
as you reference but it's not going
they're not going to proactively go out
because of this bill uh to to go out
that will be the Federal ice Department
job and I appreciate that answer one
final follow-up question um so uh in
looking at uh in looking at um HB 511 uh
do you have a a copy in front of you uh
I I have my testimony but I I know the
copy in my head um so uh what I'm
referring to for members of the
committee on uh uh on go I can find the
bill on uh page two uh line
32 where it
reads
uh accept as otherwise authorized the
state entity Etc may not prohibit or in
any way restrict a law enforcement
agency from taking any of the following
actions with re respect to information
regarding a person's immigration status
if we were to change that to reflect
what the conversation we've just had to
read instead to take the any of the
following actions with respect to
information regarding an inmate's uh
immigration status uh would you be fine
with that no I I like the wording as is
for the person it still doesn't direct
the law enforcement agencies to go out
and enforce the immigration laws but I
don't see why we would put further
handcuffs on law enforcement and their
authorities uh thank you for taking my
question are you uh familiar with the
lakan Riley act that was recently passed
by Congress I I am and I applaud its
passage how would that work with this
bill if it were to become law well
simply any new especially the lake and
Riley act or any new legislation or laws
that come out of the federal government
the new hampsh New Hampshire local law
enforcement state law enforcement would
be obliged to work with Federal
immigration officials to enforce those
you I have a question um representative
last year this bill or a version of this
bill um came before us and we we ended
up amending it a little bit um because
there was some concern that it was a
little too broad as far as the portion
that says they um will let me see where
I can find it that that they will do any
their best efforts um we we we changed
that a little bit to narrow it down if I
recall and it said to the extent
possible and their ability to safely do
so shall comply with immigration detain
is discovered during the investigation
of a violation of New Hampshire law um
that was to make sure that it was not
deemed to be them becoming federal
police officers but if they were
investigating in the Hampshire crime and
they became aware of this then they had
to follow it um what are your thoughts
on that uh you know humbly I'm I'm one
of 400 and it's now the committee's bill
after I've introduced it so please feel
free to to have discussions among the
committee but that does not seem like a
change I would oppose okay thank you and
it wouldn't change the the the sentiment
of the bill it would just um narrow it
so that we focus on exactly what we were
interested in nothing more um further
Muse have you reviewed the text of this
bill with anyone in law enforcement and
if you have what kind of feedback have
you got but I'm not thank
you representative
new thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I we've heard a lot today
about um sex trafficking and and the
need to really address that and one of
the things that was um noted was that
oftentimes people's um undocumented
status is uh a reason why they are not
um willing to speak up for themselves
people who are victims in that situation
are you concerned that um bills like
this might hinder people I I actually
come from one of the um towns in in
chesher County who has actually what
it's called as a welcoming uh it's a a
welcome I'm blanking on what it is but
welcome uh city um Proclamation um and
what it says is that we just won't
unnecessarily um address and what we
have found um the reason why we did that
is because uh it it made it so that we
could uh that we could actually fight
crime better because we had open
communication right it allows for open
communication so this is a situation
that we've been talking about today
around sex trafficking and and this
among other uh criminal behavior is
hindered by people's inability uh or you
know the perceived inability to be able
to speak with police if they believe
that they will be removed from the
country that type of situation are you
concerned about inhibiting um um law
enforcement from addressing crime
because they cannot have open lines of
communication with people um with an
undocumented status I I appreciate the
question I certainly appreciate the
sensitivity of the question I truly
believe that under this bill law
enforcement at the local and the state
level will be able to work to prevent
further crimes from taking place that
sunlight is the best disinfectant and
that this will give them the tools not
handcuff our law enforcement from not
being able to enforce the law uh and be
able to work with Federal authorities so
that we can actually tackle uh human
trafficking at the source which is our
right now mainly our Southern border um
so I think as we just continue to have
the conversation on immigration more
enforcement not less will lead to less
human
trafficking thank
you see you no further questions thank
much just so everyone um is aware we
only have until 5:00 to get out of the
building so I would ask you to please
keep your testimony piffy if you might
um and non-repetitive I'm not going to
put a limit on anyone at this point um
so I'm just going to it's going to be a
Scouts Honor kind of thing so please
keep it as short as you can at that I
good
afternoon um thank you to having me here
my name is Mary jores
um I feel very very bad hearing
everything
here I came here as a immigrant and I
was illegal to because when I came I
everything um with my everything
my was my
trip but it was a little bit it was a
problem but I couldn't go back to Congo
where I come from the Republic of Congo
I came here in
1990 I was nurse when I was in
Congo I came here year I was in age of
32 years old today I'm
67 I'm a mother of a four children three
Manchester I came in Manchester February
illegal because I didn't have a my
passport always expired and did I um I
fil for asalm but all those time I was I
was just working without V when I was in
in
Boston and I know one day I was looking
for I was having apartment because being
with a roommate was sometime give a
problem but to have a apartment I I have
a studio I PID that studio
but the lady who was the owner tried to
give him a hard time I said I'm not
going to be in that place but the real
state to giveing me money they was not
giving me money but I called the police
but I didn't have a paperwork I didn't
have my passport was expired but the
police helped
me I was not speak English very well but
that's TR I to speak myself the police
told them to looking for a place for me
to look another apartment and they say
if she can add $50 and the um I do that
I give the the $50 they give me a part
me and I was living there until I
Manchester if I'm today become even a
state representative working inside the
uh be in school board and they do all of
those work I'm doing inside the
community is just because of
Injustice the suffering
because when you don't have a paperwork
how they can use it for
working and they W giving me even the
strength one day I decide I'm going to
school I decided to go back to school
after when I have three
kids because I was nurse but I suffer
this just because of people who feel
because you have a uh skin color or
because you speak English um you don't
speak English very well that they can
make you do everything it's just like a
they say now but I was a illegal person
at the
time but I went back to school I do my
my I do my bachelor degree I get to my
my diploma
for uh Human Services I get a bachelor
for Human Services and I get to my
master in um
organizational management and
Leadership when even I was going to do
all of those things because even I
become a citizen I become everything but
I was illegal person but I didn't do
crime I didn't do something
bad but to know everything what I was
going
through that make me strong make me to
help others makeing me to stand with all
those migrant even the mothers the women
I do like a Empower women I just make
all those we all this just because to
help others and all of us we came here
as a immigrant even all of them you be
there there is your parent maybe came
here your grandparent great great
grandparent came here as a immigrant but
they didn't just have a p uh they they
not become just illegal at the
time and they
we came here it's not just
because is a sometime is a choice and it
does choice too because for where we
come from what is a problem like when I
came here what was problem behind me
that why I couldn't even go back they
tell me if you come back here you're
going to be in
trouble but I didn't go back because I
don't want to be in trouble it's a
country that the Democratic Republic of
Congo is a country that have all the
resource is the richest country of of
the world all of those who sell phone
those computers everything we have those
everything we have we're doing come from
Congo but the people in Congo suffer why
just because for um they suffer because
for people want to take everything in
granted the women become user the women
become um the violence all those become
the weapon of War why because just
because to get the the resources that
the reason people are coming sometime
when they come here they feel
safe and now because somebody's
illegal you didn't get a paperwork yet
or working with a work Perman I don't
know that they can just bring somebody
back and tomorrow what's going to
be we say we are
chrisan this
election I'm going to tell you the truth
this election was about the
Christian lot Republican they need to
know most of those people who are the
church is Christian because for abortion
they didn't want to vote for the
Democrat the vote the
Republican most of those immigrant
Christian they didn't vote to the
Democrat they said they're going to vote
to the Republican because for
abortion because they didn't they don't
support
abortion now the same
people they don't want to see them the
same people they don't want to hear from
them be immigrants
myself my neighbor born here in
Manchester but he was alone after the
wife died the children back go back home
they the children not his children but
was the the step's kids they didn't want
to help him my neighbor was suffer but
as a immigrant I stand with with him I
did everything support we immigrant we
do a lot of work that
sometime the the migrant thems the the
legal people cannot do it but I I think
so I don't want to stay too long I'm so
sorry
um focus on the bill please on what you
think is bad about the bill yeah for
this bill that why I came for this bill
for the 5 101 I I really
um I cannot support this but I think so
you guys need
to look the Immigrant come in this
country they work very hard like I did I
work very hard and we help we do lot of
work you can go everywhere go to E seals
go everywhere you're going to see just
immigrant doing all those kind of work
the work that is not because for I think
so people we are here for for life is
now because to do the crme somebody who
do the crme is the person who do the
crme but not everybody not just because
they're
illegal thank you thank you very much
next and the chair at this time
thank you for the record I'm Janine nder
I represent the town of marac Hillsboro
12 and I know that is it's difficult to
vote for a bill like this after hearing
the testimony you just heard and this
isn't about people uh families and this
is about the ones that we don't know who
they are this is a bill that I've
sponsored in the past this is my my file
I have two files lots of information
We're a nation of laws and every country
in the world has borders and they
protect their
borders I've been to the Border
twice I've talked to the border of
Patrol I've talked to the sheriffs I've
talked to the
ranchers I saw the cages that were built
under the abama
administration but we were not allowed
to see the children but I can tell from
my conversations with them that they
they they cared about those children and
they was assured that they take care of
them so I just wanted to get that out
there
I been on the Rio Grand in the boat the
cartel waved to us they wanted us to
know that we saw them we have a have a
big opioid problem in New Hampshire as
of last year we were second only to um
West Virginia with the opio problem so
how are these drugs coming in well we
have an open border we have people
flowing over the Border it's wide open
I've seen it we don't know who they are
we don't know where they come from we
don't know what their inent are they're
smuggling people they're smuggling drugs
they're smuggling children for sex
trafficking in the interest of time I'm
not going to take any questions but I do
support the Bill thank you thank you
represent
than
sorry thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is yil Binet I'm
the legal director at the
ACLU uh of New Hampshire and we are here
in opposition to HB 511 I know that we
only have half an hour and I'm
respectful of the committee's time and
the the time of folks behind me who
haven't yet spoken so I just want to
make a few points real quick about this
bill and I think first is with respect
to uh the statement made um about the
sponsor that this isn't going to commere
I'm just summarizing but this isn't
going to commere local police department
resources and I I just don't agree with
that based on the text um of the bill
and I wanted to flag that because the
language in the bill is very Broad and I
do think is phrased as a mandate with
respect to what our local police have to
do right so for example no uh government
entity shall quote knowingly enact issue
adop promulgate enforce Etc any
Sanctuary policy with that policy being
defined broadly with respect to detainer
compliance and the bill for also two
goes so far of course to state that law
enforcement must use best efforts to
support the enforcement of federal
immigration law and I think when you
look at kind of all those Provisions
together particularly when you also look
at the penalties that are attached to
non-compliance I think what you have is
a mandate for local police to do the
work of federal immigration enforcement
I think really commanders our local
police um whose jobs are not to enforce
federal civil immigration laws but to
enforce state and federal crimes and
those are very different things in fact
and that gets to my second point with
respect to mandating uh compliance with
detainers detainer is a request uh
that's all it is a request by federal
immigration enforcement for local and
County officials to hold someone for ice
for up to 48 hours and so there just by
its terms if you mandate
compliance with that detainer um you are
they're effectively commandeering the
resources of local police and that's not
just we're not talking here I want to be
very clear about state or federal crimes
we're talking about civil immigration
violations as a uh representative sure
mentioned before being undocumented by
itself is not a crime that is different
from though right if someone knowingly
crosses the Border whether it's a
northern border or the southern border
that is a crime but being undocumented
by itself is not it is a civil
immigration violation so when you
require local police to hold people on
civil immigration violations it also
creates constitutional concerns right
because there's no indicia that a crime
has actually been committed yet you're
requiring our local law enforcement to
hold those individuals lastly and this
is another reason why law enforcement
have opposed last year opposed ident an
identical Bill and I've attached that
letter to my testimony is that when you
ask local law enforcement to do federal
immigration enforcement again for civil
immigration violations separate and
apart we're not talking about crimes if
you commit a crime there's no sanctuary
in New Hampshire right you should be
arrested and prosecuted but when you
require local police to do civil
immigration violation enforcement you
create real concerns that community
members immigrants won't go to police
for help won't go to police if they're a
victim won go to police to be a witness
or to report a crime and that's one of
the many reasons why law enforcement um
you know have have raised concerns about
these types uh of legislation so with
that I'll just
rest on what I've submitted uh to the
committee and I want to express my
gratitude and appreciation for
consideration uh of our concerns which
we think are are profoundly uh
problematic with respect to this bill
and we'd ask that this bill be itl thank
you thank you um if it's any consolation
I've requested an amendment so that it
matches the bill that we actually went
to Florida the Roy Amendment last year
yes I thought that might be happening
yeah and I I realize you may not support
that whole but I think you found it much
more palatable do you want me to respond
to that or or just
feele um you know I think it goes
without saying we did have concerns with
that Amendment it did take out the best
efforts language which I want to express
my gratitude for the chair for doing
that because I do think that is deeply
problematic language but my recollection
of that amendment is that it it
continued to have um some detainer
compliance language in it that we had
issu issues with um for all the Reon I
just said but in addition Our concern
with detainers is that there's no baked
in due process associated with them and
so we would continue to have those
concerns which I know is no surprise Mr
chairman thank you thank you uh
representative PR has a question if you
don't mind of course of course kind of
confused happens to me a lot it does so
how can you be undocumented in this
country without knowingly crossing a
border oh it happens all the time and
that's that's that happens through Visa
overstays which is actually the kind of
highest category of undocumented
individuals in fact um it is a minority
of undocumented individuals who are just
crossing the New Hampshire or New Mexico
border without authorization most occur
through individuals who've actually
entered the country lawfully through a
Visa and then overstay that by itself is
not a federal crime though it is a
federal civil immigration violation and
that distinction I think is material for
um the custody custody issues that I
raised in my testimony to be clear
though a second subsequent entry without
being documented is a federal crime is
if you cross the border yes yes that is
that is correct I'm not disputing that
at all Mr chairman has has the Supreme
Court at all come down on this this
issue of detainers um no no there's
multiple multiple other federal courts
not at the Supreme Court level that have
AAL waed
to is there a circuit split you know I I
don't think so um I mean that's
something I can I can I can evaluate I I
we I know site in our testimony a lot of
the federal courts that have looked at
detainers and have expressed some
concerns with respect to detention to
detention purely on um detainers so
thank
you um we have to leave at 5: so please
the the environment uh for this bill is
a little bit different than the one in
2024 uh the fiscal note is basically the
same uh my my question is is what impact
will the federal changes in Immigration
policy that have been announced over the
last couple of days and that also are
are being uh contemplated in Washington
DC what will that what impact will that
have on on the number of detainers that
are out there and the requirements on
New Hampshire and local police is there
any way to estimate that at this point
it's it's a great question I I I don't
know I have some guesses but I I'm
always hesitant to guess you know being
a lawyer I think we probably can I think
it's probably safe to say we're going to
see increased use of detainers and these
documents being funnel to loc and law
enforcement to ask local law enforcement
to do detentions with local resources if
that assumption is true then the
concerns that we've raised would be even
more pronounced because they would
require
local you know local talented
communities to pay for those detentions
for the the two days up to two days that
they'd be authorized under under a
detainer thank you thank
you represent Newman this is just one
more thing about whether you're illegal
in this country without papers yes cross
the border and you're in the country
just by not having
papers what what are your comments about
whether that's due process or whether
you are in fact illegal and even if you
come in on like a Visa you explained
that one y but if you came in and then
you cross the border illegally just are
they illegal or not just because they
have committed a crime and nothing else
the guy's just standing there and he may
have crossed the border yeah I could
only speak legally because that's my
training and I think that is the most
accurate way to talk about
um how to categorize certain groups of
individuals so I think saying some
someone is illegal or not is not an
accurate reflection of someone's status
you have individuals that have committed
federal crimes by being in the United
States what I mean by that is they have
crossed the border once or maybe twice
without authorization which is a crime
or you have individuals who cross the
border they had lawful authority to
cross the border and this is most
instances by the way they've overstate a
Visa by some way shape or form they are
not here lawfully but they haven't
committed a crime they've committed a
civil immigration violation I think
those are accurate descriptors for those
those groups and individuals and that
becomes meaningful here with respect to
what the authority is for local police
to detain someone if there's a crime yes
if there isn't cons constitutional
concerns thank you to the best your
knowledge are there different types of
detainers are there criminal detainers
versus civil detainers I I'm I'm only
aware of the the detainer form which I
think is principally used for just
anyone that's undocumented so it could
be I suppose it could be someone who's
crossed without authorization no but I
mean someone who perhaps is wanted for
murder um well if they're wanted for
murder and they haven't Ser they haven't
been arrested or served their sentence
they should be arrested they will be
arrested would that be reflected on the
detainer form no but that the detainer
usually comes in in that instance after
someone is actually served D their
sentence so they'd be a criminal War
yeah so that so that person will that
person the murder in that example that
person would have been adjudicated for
murder would have been arrested
prosecuted as they should right what
we're talking about are individuals who
haven't committed crimes um you know who
visa overstate and whether or not
there's authority to to hold them and
require local police to use their
resources to hold them and that's where
we have concerns thank you
representative
Sher brief question but I'm going to put
you on the spot fair enough um
Professor um fortunately you're not a
former student of mine um I'm looking at
uh page
32 thank you we ran out of copies I'm
sorry fa enough you very much page two
line 32 yeah and that that that that
reads I asked uh representative Sweeny
this question uh to preface that State
entity may not prohibit or in any way
restrict a law enforcement agency from
taking any of the following actions with
respect to information regarding a
person's immigration status now let's go
back to what you said there are civil
detainers somebody hasn't been charged
in the state with a crime there's just a
civil detainer um and there the other
group is people who've been charged with
the crime the police department is aware
that there is a detainer uh
uh if we CH and and my understanding is
some many people's desire is to have
police departments go ahead and call ICE
when a person's charged with a crime and
they know they have a detainer and let
them know that they have the person in
custody if we were to change the word a
persons into an inmates so and an inmate
is previously defined as somebody in
custody
uh in some fashion uh would you be
comfortable with that change to narrow
down what this bill is it paying
attention to I think that would be much
more palatable and I I want to just kind
of give two reasons for that first
you're cabining the kind of Ambit of
this bill to not individuals who are out
on the street or driving you're cabining
it to individuals who are already
detained in some way shape or form I
think that
is um would narrow it in ways that are
helpful I I think I would still want to
think a little bit more about it but I
think that would be a favorable change
and in addition if we're not talking
about detention but we're talking about
just uh local law enforcement or a local
governing body just providing the
information um that's not as much of a
burden obviously on them um and I would
be maybe maybe still concerned but far
less concerned um with that I also think
that like happens pretty regularly um I
could tell you like I'm pretty sure
County jails do that regularly as much
as I may like that or not so if you
wanted to memorialize that to say you
know we think you should do that that is
far better than saying you also need to
hold them for ice you need to stop them
you need to detain them you know I think
that that is more dramatic of an
intrusion and I think that that more
dramatic intrusion is reflected in in
the current version of this Bill thank
you my understanding is uh that's the
policy of the Portsmouth Police
Department I believe also the policy the
Manchester Police Department uh to to uh
call when they've arrested someone they
know there's a detainer yeah absolutely
I'm glad you agree because that's what
the amendment does um well I think oh
the amendment does more than that can I
respond it does that as well I I it does
that as well exactly but I think it goes
beyond that I'm sorry to to be difficult
that's okay I'm I heard you um all right
no further questions thank you thank you
Mr
chairman the next one the chair calls
Kevin um I can't read anything after
that anyone here named Kevin
Mo good afternoon members of the House
my name is Kevin Moore I just want to
say something real quick thanks from the
Upper Valley volunteer at a homeless
shelter um the homeless shelter is based
in Vermont uh the Upper Valley Haven um
this bill would be totally
uh bad um these are our brothers and
sisters
and if we if this bill passes I don't
know um these are human beings these
folks should not
be punished they should not be jailed
they should have freedom like myself and
you all sitting around this
table is that what we want do we want to
put people in jail do we want to lock
Randall again please um all the
remaining Witnesses remember we're down
to like 14 minutes so please be fair to
your
other fellow witnesses as quick as you
can is especially if you've turned in
copies of your testimony please proceed
chairman Roy and other distinguished
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify in strong
support of HB 511 on behalf of the
Federation for American Immigration
Reform as you heard my name is Sherry
rendle I'm the director of state and
local engagement for the organization
we're a nonpartisan organization of
concerned individuals who believe our
immigration laws must be reformed to
serve our nation's interests we've were
founded in 1979 we have 3 million
members and supporters Nationwide 4,000
here in the state of New Hampshire if
enacted HB 511 will prohibit
jurisdictions from employing dangerous
Sanctuary policies that provide a safe
haven in which illegal aliens can work
and live without fear of apprehension by
federal immigration
authorities I just want to kind of touch
on some of the points that were raised
before um I'm not saying everyone who
comes here is a criminal alien uh what
we're saying is that individuals who
enter through our back door and not our
front door have not been vetted and
their intentions are unknown even those
who have entered legally such as
students or tourists and overstay their
visas remaining in this United States
illegally have not had the same thorough
background that is performed by someone
who is legally immigrating to the United
States um I just want to clearly state
that just in the last fiscal year there
were 410 individuals who were on the
terrorist watch list that were
encountered at our Northern borders and
an additional three that were
encountered between the ports of Entry
just to highlight that we don't know
who's coming
in sanctuary policies come in all shapes
and sizes as you've heard some are
written some are not some are enacted
through local laws while some are
welcoming resolutions generally they bar
state and local officials including law
enforcement from asking lawfully stopped
or detained individuals about their
immigration status and from reporting or
otherwise cooperating with Federal
immigration officials regardless of how
they're adopted and what form they take
they are Sanctuary policies there are
several in New Hampshire that um there
have been a proliferation of counties
Chester County Deerfield Dublin Durham
Hanover Harrisonville Lebanon lime and
Manchester they don't call themselves
Sanctuary yet their practices make them
function as sanctuary cities a question
was raised about whether there are any
uh law enforcement policies against um
against detainers Hillsboro um County uh
Correction Facility actually does have a
policy that um does not cooperate with
detainers um one of the things that was
raised was the issue of whether it will
uh reduce the reporting of crimes and
having people come forward about being
criminalized besides the fact that
anonymous tips can be given um a number
of programs allow state and local police
to encourage victim and witness
cooperation by granting lawful status to
illegal aliens who Aid in the
prosecution of criminals if they provide
helpful IM uh information to the police
they can qualify for a UTS or vawa
non-immigrant VISA which ultimately
allows them to apply for permanent legal
status in the United States Sanctuary
policies actually prevent illegal aliens
victims of crime from taking advantage
of these types of programs in addition
there was a recent study by the center
for immigration studies that looked at
the data from the Department of
Justice's National crime victim
victimization survey and it shows that
immigrant victimizations are just as
likely in some cases more likely to be
reported to the police than against the
native
form uh one of the things that I would
like to say is um detainers are issued
by uh more than just the immigration
officials they're issued by the US
Marshall other local law enforcement
agencies and um police departments even
from other states there are no issues
raised about honoring those DET
detainers so why are we raising the
issue about honoring an immigration
detainer and
if the immigration detainers aren't
honored that doesn't mean that ice won't
go after someone in your communities and
if they come into your communities it
poses a danger to the public because
they're now getting people off the
street as opposed to in a secure
location like a jail the other thing is
if they have to come in there's probably
going to be a much wider net cast and
people who might not have been caught up
could be caught up because of that so
Sanctuary policies could in effect have
the opposite um
impact and with that I'll um allow
questions thank you thank you we
appreciate your time um we really have
Costello hello uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh my name is
AA Castillo I come from
Manchester um I am in opposition to this
bill um this bill would further erode
the trust that the police department
have worked so hard to build in all
kinds of immigrant
communities uh it is unnecessary because
the police already collaborates with ice
I can tell you many people that I know
that have committed crimes that have
gone to jail including the brothers of
my adopted son ages ago and they go
They're sent to prison and then the day
they're released from their thing
immigration is waiting for them outside
right police departments that have put
policies in place they know what they're
doing and what's good for the
communities not one of them has uh
forbidden from collaborating with ice
they turn anybody that commits a crime
they go uh through the process with ice
but we do not need to test the police
with enforcing federal law which is not
their job they're already asked to be
social workers drug counselors they do
all kind kind of stuff that psychologist
they do all kinds of stuff that is not
really their stuff we do not need to do
the work for the fs that get paid way
more than they do by the way so please
just you know have the reasoning this is
not going to make a community safer and
that it really doesn't make any
difference anyways because we already
are protected by from who we need to be
protected and no human being is illegal
thank you God bless you thank you God
bless you too next
Wellington good afternoon uh um and
thank you I'll be extremely brief um
there's just a couple points I want to
follow up on I'm Christine Wellington
I'm from Derry New Hampshire I'm also a
a member of the New Hampshire immigrants
rights Network we did uh send you a
letter that more in detail outlines our
positions uh I want to say that uh first
our our major concern isn't the the um
carrying out of criminal law enforcement
by any law enforcement entity that finds
itself within the Hampshire whether it's
federal state local um this is about um
this bill that appears to prioritize the
enforcement of civil uh immigration law
over the interests of the communities
that our local and state police
departments serve I I just want to also
um emphasize again that the detainers
that are referenced in this um Bill are
civil detainers that um are based on the
immigration officers belief that there's
probable cause that the um immigrant is
removable from the country and and if
that person is removable their case will
be processed through an administrative
law Court not the criminal courts we're
not talking about enforcement of
criminal law uh the best efforts issue I
just there's one other point we also are
worried that the that best efforts
remove so much discretion that even in
the cases where somebody is a victim of
um a crime or a witness to a crime or
otherwise cooperating in a police
investigation of a crime uh where that
person might be eligible for um some
kind of uh t or U Visa or or something
else that it may cause the police to
still feel they have to report that
person to immigration authorities
last Point um it I think it's important
to note that if there is liability
attached to unlawful seizures of people
based on detainers the federal
government will not indemnify our
officers and will not pay the liability
cost and we ask the um the committee to
consider that as
well that is an important point of
exposure thank you
minutes thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'm Bob Dunn the director
of public policy for the Roman Catholic
dasis of Manchester and I'm here today
speaking at the speed of sound on behalf
of Bishop Peter
labashi uh to respectfully oppose this
bill um just want to highlight uh pretty
much one thing as the folks in this room
are well aware um and I've been working
in the state government the legislature
since I was an Assistant Attorney
General back in the late 80s and the
assistant Commissioner of safety in the
early and mid 90s and one of the first
things I learned was that the department
of safety and the New Hampshire Chiefs
of police are never shy about coming to
the legislature to make suggestions
about legislation that will protect the
public safety and so I think it's highly
notable that this legislation although
it's intended as a public safety measure
does not come from the very people that
we have tasked with uh being responsible
for Public Safety in our cities and
towns and uh the police Chiefs uh in
many of or some of those cities and
towns uh I understand do have uh a do
exercise some discretion with respect to
how they deal with these detainers
discretion that would be removed by this
piece of
legislation uh and they feel obviously
that it's important to do that in order
to ensure that those lines of
communication and Trust are maintained
and that therefore crimes don't go unre
reported um and so the to the extent
that our Chiefs have made decisions
about trying to exercise some discretion
here I think that we need to rely on
them to know best what will protect the
Public Safety in this state thank
you thank you and as a Catholic you can
pass my hello onto his Eminence but I
eileene
Brady thank you I appreciate
it Reverend Jonathan Hopkins I have
Britain testimony I'll be happy to
submit instead and I didn't bring enough
copy so you might have
to thank you I appreciate it Reverend
Margarets and last but not least
Margaret
Burns oh that's too bad anyone else here
who who would like to testify in the
next one minute and seeing no one I
hearby closes public hearing I had an
intention of um possibly opening
executive on this um at this point I'm
looking at an amendment and that's not
going to happen so just um pay attention
I'll let everybody know when and if I
need them to be here or I will get who I
e